[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau de Tout le
monde en parle l'émission pas comme les
autres vous connaissez le principe tout
le monde en parle alors tout le monde en
parle
magnéto Serge gentil
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment ça va Philippe
comment ça va
alors Philippe Talia n'est pas là non
ben non c'est pour éviter plein
d'embêtements tous les garçons email de
Julien du Havre qui dit Thierry je n'en
peux plus après ton émission je dors sur
la béquille
Talia anthemini voilà allez reviens
quand le remède il va pouvoir dormir ce
soir tranquille mais samedi prochain
elle sera là aïe aïe
et maintenant mesdames messieurs
j'accueille notre première invité de la
soirée Gérard Jugnot
Virginio bonsoir vous avez déclaré
l'acteur est passé du muet au parlant et
du parlant à la promotion là par exemple
sur le film oui mais j'ai tourné deux
semaines et je dois faire trois ou
quatre semaines de promotion c'est plus
long de faire la promotion que le film
en même temps
merci Gérard Jugnot
[Applaudissements]
alors vous êtes né en 1951 dans le 19e à
Paris votre grand-père était bouché il a
une conduite héroïque pendant la guerre
il a refusé de faire du marché noir son
grand-père donc évidemment la libération
et les piles clients puisqu'il est pas
de viande voilà quand vous dites que
vous êtes nostalgique des promenades en
brouette avec lui il vous promenait
vraiment dans une brouette
salut sinon il y a des trucs il
fouillent vous avez des enquêteurs
dans le musée de la
qui n'est pas la femelle du loyer
qui avait à l'époque une émission qui
s'appelle l'homme des vœux je sais pas
si seul c'est un apéritif il fallait
découper la la rondelle on y arrive on y
arrive dans son porte-monnaie et puis il
y avait il y avait dans la rue qui
racontait des conneries et quand on dit
vous êtes comme des vœux voilà on gagne
100 francs et puis si on avait des
capsules on gagne 100 francs 1200 et mon
grand-père qui habitait dans la dans le
Loiret à cheval dans un endroit assez
perdu où il y avait aucune raison que
l'homme ne devait pas il avait dans son
porte-monnaie 15 euh
il l'a jamais rencontré l'homme des vœux
et je trouve ça très jolie vous êtes un
peu empaillé avec lui parce que c'est
vrai qu'à un moment tout le monde lui
dit votre père est plombier et en fait
il écrivait lui aux gens en disant non
pas du tout je suis patron d'une
entreprise de plomberie directeur d'une
entreprise directeur d'une entreprise
on fait gaffe non mais c'est vrai c'est
arrivé à beaucoup de gens qui ont réussi
par la suite quand vous étiez petit vous
viviez dans un milieu assez modeste et
vous dites j'avais l'impression d'être
un fils de Prince enlever par des
bohémiens ça vous aviez pas un le
sentiment d'appartenir à la famille dans
laquelle vous étiez né tous les enfants
sont comme ça on se prend le choix avec
ses parents on dit mais c'est pas
possible mes parents sont beaucoup plus
intelligents beaucoup plus
compréhensible beaucoup plus beau plus
plus riche plus bon c'est des trucs
d'enfants et dur et dites-moi l'histoire
de la lapine pleine c'est vrai ou c'est
faux parce que moi j'ai lu que votre
père et votre mère avait reçu pour leur
mariage en cadeau de votre grand-mère
une lapine pleine non non pas du tout
c'est pas mes parents non mes parents
dans attends je viens pas mes parents
sont les gens sérieux j'ai connu
quelqu'un comme ça qui qui m'a raconté
que pour son mariage on lui avait offert
comme cadeau de mariage une lapine plaît
parce que c'était juste après c'était
très pauvre enfin mes parents n'étaient
pas pauvres
et ils sont élevés dans les choses
sociales ils sont arrivés à quelque
chose de très bien pour eux comme mes
parents voilà alors vous dites en
parlant de vos parents j'aurais préféré
qu'il me donne meulière ou Mozart mais
finalement ils m'ont donné la
gourmandise et le cholestérol
positifs sur André donc il y a pas de
souci vous inquiétez pas moi je parfois
une bonne terrine que fait ma mère
admirablement c'est aussi bon que Mozart
c'est vrai qu'elle adolescence comme
beaucoup d'adolescents vers l'âge de 18
ans et très révolté et vous écriviez sur
les murs de votre chambre
on choisit ses amis on choisit pas sa
famille non c'est vrai oui bien sûr mais
tous les enfants tous les adolescents
qui ont des crises
[Musique]
je leur dois beaucoup de choses
toutes ces incompréhension peut-être si
ça se trouve c'est de l'amour vous êtes
parti de tout le monde n'a pas la chance
d'être né orphelin puis après ça s'est
arrangé le temps aidant on se rend
compte qu'on doit des choses à ses
parents et vous dites aujourd'hui je me
trouve en train de répéter à mon fils
des phrases entières comme disait mon
père et que je trouvais conne à l'époque
ouais mais là vous parlez que de mon
père mais ma mère est très importante
attendez on en parlait la deuxième
partie de l'émission
mais ça a eu un intérêt pour vous cette
névrose précoce parce que ça vous a
dirigé vers la création artistique d'une
certaine façon
peut-être qu'elle avait pas eu cette
rébellion contre votre famille peut-être
vous auriez jamais créé c'était pas que
contre ma famille c'était contre j'avais
peur de m'ennuyer quoi j'étais un garçon
très très timide donc je pense que
le spectacle c'était une manière de
faire briller un peu tout ça et de
sortir de d'avoir des des colonnes faire
partie de ce tout Paris qui chante et
qui rit
alors vous commencez par faire un
court-métrage qui s'appelle GAGOS et
c'est l'histoire d'un type qui va
toujours le côté marrant des choses hein
non mais GAGOS c'est énorme c'est
l'histoire d'un mec qui imagine une
connerie à partir de chaque chose qu'il
voit évidemment la définition de la
comédie oui
de les transformer comme ça surtout il y
avait un enterrement et puis il y avait
il essaie de vendre des farces et
attrapes pour le dans cette église là il
y avait le calice Baveur il y avait
l'hostie élastique il y avait le
sur la moquette voilà à une communion
j'ai un cousin qui a mis une fausse
merde de chien comme ça c'est très bien
imité sur la table et ça c'est trouvé ça
à formidable espèce d'intrusion de la
faute d'une vocation ah oui ça c'est je
crois que c'est ça qui a fait qui m'a
fait ça fait en tournée il y a quand
même
dès l'âge de 14 ans vous commencez à
faire des films alors en super 8 double
finger c'est une parodie de Goldfinger
c'est assez drôle c'est une comédie
c'est un Gaga c'est pétrifiant où on
torturait avec une lampe à souder brûler
les pieds alors il y avait un plan sur
les pieds comme ça et puis on remontait
et j'avais la fumée par la bouche
alors votre vocation prend son élan au
lycée Pasteur à Neuilly quand vous
rencontrez l'ermite clavier Michel Blanc
vous écrivez des sketchs qui deviendront
les le font des des premiers spectacles
du splendide alors l'aventure du
splendide on a parlé la semaine dernière
ici avec votre ami Thierry Lhermitte
comment
alors dans notre série donc consacré au
roi du rire après Thierry Lhermitte on a
géant alors il nous a parlé de vous
alors là je vais faire magnéto Serge ce
que je voulais dire d'abord c'est
qu'effectivement il y a quelqu'un qui
m'a envoyé un email en disant j'ai un
chien qui s'appelle magnétos Serge et
chaque fois que tu fais manif le sien
sur ce retour donc je suis absolument
désolé
à l'époque de
pasteur
vous avez des relations homosexuelles
avec Gérard Jugnot
oui
récemment vous avez décidé de faire un
petit essai tous les deux à nouveau
ensemble
il veut pas alors voilà le problème
voilà c'est voilà moi je pense qu'il
faut rien n'est perdu je te le dis j'ai
la caméra je te le dis j'ai je suis
encore là et je crois que je t'attendrai
toute ma vie
et voilà
une belle histoire d'amour
donc il nous a lancé un appel
et ça votre père votre père ne le savait
pas non on s'est enfilé une faute
dans un spectacle on faisait un numéro
de de main
et
d'ailleurs c'était moi l'actif
et voilà ce qui est dit ça va être
repris
la semaine prochaine c'est la chaîne de
l'amitié risquant Christian se caresser
alors bon ça
c'est à votre père ne le savait pas il
vaut mieux qu'il le sache en revanche
quand vous vous lancez dans la carrière
il vous dites tu es un futur clochard
c'est vrai qu'après le grand-père bouché
lui patron de PME d'un seul coup il
avait l'impression que vous ne
continuiez pas cette ascension sociale
qui était celle de la famille juniot non
enfin je crois que la grande inquiétude
de mon père qui lui avait travaillé
toute sa vie pour arriver à une belle
situation comme on dit il avait peur que
moi je travaille toute ma vie pour avoir
pour ne pas avoir de situation
donc c'est vrai que la première fois que
je lui ramené c'était tout fier j'ai
ramené la fiche de paye artiste de
complément le mot complément
l'anéantique mais bon j'avais 20 ans bon
ben ça nous ramène justement un meilleur
espoir féminin quand il a eu la promo du
film votre père il était complètement
rassuré parce qu'un soir vous l'avez
invité à dîner avec Michel Drucker c'est
Michel Drucker
a appelé à la maison il est tombé sur ma
mère Odette et
ce qu'il faut quand même parler
c'est elle qui m'a donné aussi la force
qu'elle était beaucoup plus positive que
mon père mais et donc ma mère a dit bah
tiens Michel Drucker nous a appelé pour
nous inviter dîner et il l'a envoyé
chier dans un commentaire
à Michel de rappeler mon père pour qu'il
le croit voilà
c'était du dîner aussi Odette André
Gérard mimi toute la bande donc tout le
monde et alors là quand il a vu que
Michel Drucker vous tutoyez là il a dit
c'est c'est gagné c'est une espèce
d'aboutissement
et
pourquoi il vient pas avec vous de temps
en temps on est dans les émissions
c'était l'interview papa maman
le pire est à venir Gérard Jugnot
le pire est à venir je vous ai concocté
une petite interview pour vous
spécialement voici l'interview alerte
rose
[Musique]
voilà Laurent Baffie ne bouge plus
pendant le jingle et c'est très bien
comme ça voilà ma fille pas bouger alors
allons-y
le lieu idéal pour faire l'amour
Michel Rocard il a répondu tout de suite
moi je pense qu'un lit c'est ce mieux
c'est ce qu'il a répondu
c'est quelqu'un dans le public
une réputation vous maintenant non on
fait ça dans les chiottes
le lieu pour vous où il serait
absolument impossible de faire l'amour
je dirais dans un endroit public
pourtant je t'ai vu une fois
bien alors attention là c'est beaucoup
plus complexe est-ce que vous avez
besoin de faire l'amour pour aimer ou
d'aimer pour faire l'amour
d'aimer pour faire l'amour ah bon très
féminin ouais vous pouvez pas faire
l'amour comme ça sans aimer peut-être
que sa femme regarde aussi
que cet homme n'est pas c'est une
explique ainsi
parce que je l'ai vu choper aussi donc
c'est un jeu de l'esprit ça n'a rien à
voir avec notre épouse c'est un jeu de
l'esprit tout ça fait est-ce que vous
préférez une femme qui baise bien mais
qui est infidèle ou une femme qui baise
mal mais qui est fidèle
je suis très admis avec Michel vous êtes
sur la même politique hein
est-ce que vous préférez qu'elle vous
quitte pour un homme ou pour une femme
son café
mais pourquoi pas dans un couple vous
préférez tous dire ou rien se dire
de moyenne de
tous dire et rien savoir
pas tout la vérité n'est pas toujours
bonne année en même temps il faut se
dire ça comme tu veux
est-ce que embrasser c'est tromper ça
dépend ce qu'il y a dans la tronche
parce que au cinéma en embrasse d'autres
filles c'est pas grave
mais quand on dit couper tu as encore ta
langue dans la bouche de la vie
dernière question est-ce que sucer c'est
tromper
tu l'as fait aussi
sucer ou se faire sucer se faire sucer
là parce que là vous êtes en train de
sympathiser j'aurais pas
est-ce que se faire sucer c'est tromper
Clinton lui par exemple il dit que non
ça dépend par qui
est avec émilie Dequenne et Gérard
Jugnot magnétos Serge
en classe on l'appelle la girafe merci
on vous a appelé la girafe on s'est
moqué de vous probablement vous êtes un
symbole de beauté et de réussite
un ami arrive chez vous à l'improviste
en pleine nuit qu'est-ce qui vous choque
le plus qui trouve sur votre table de
nuit tu sais que je l'ai faite à Baladur
celle-là imaginez Édouard Mein Kampf ou
un godemichet Minecraft
aussi mais il sait ce que c'est qu'un
gode
incroyable
bien sûr qui s'est en Turquie ils en ont
tous
je vous aime
on est reconnais une
celle pour la pub pour les tampons
la célèbre jet seteuse
ivana Trump
de vous avoir vous auriez pu changer de
robe je traduis
bien vous étiez donc marié on va en
parler avec Donald Trump le fameux homme
de fer américain vous êtes désormais
divorcé
Massimo j'ai dit qu'il était
organisateur d'événements organisateurs
de fête mais il est aussi Mario il
présente des gens souvent et c'est
Massimo qui vous a présenté votre je
sais pas comment dire votre boy frein
actuel
oui
gentleman italien il est fabuleux génial
il est grand il est beau
nous parler de la cruauté dans la Jet 7
une personnalité absolument géniale et
tous les deux c'est les meilleurs hommes
de la terre la famille italienne
vous dites ma vie et plus agitée que le
plus agité des romans d'aventure et
c'est vrai c'est vrai que la vie Divana
Trump est une vie exceptionnelle donc on
va raconter un petit peu votre votre vie
si vous le voulez bien votre nom de
jeune fille c'est
Ivana zellenicia
alors vous êtes né au début c'est un
petit peu l'histoire de votre ami
Adriana Karembeu au départ c'est-à-dire
Ivana est né dans une ville qui
s'appelle godwaldoff qui s'appelait
godwaldov du nom du premier président
communiste de la Tchécoslovaquie godwald
Clément goldwald et donc maintenant ça a
changé de nom on
et alors c'est une ville industrielle
avec des odeurs de suie comme ça tu vois
c'est vraiment en ce qu'il faut dire
c'est que vous aviez une c'est la
dictature communiste et vous aviez vous
étiez surveillé votre famille était très
surveillé parce qu'une tente à vous en
48 en 1948 était parti donc
effectivement vous êtes partis vers le
sport vous êtes parti vers le ski
justement pour pouvoir voyager parce que
sinon il y avait aucun moyen de voyager
donc une vie un peu quand même pas
triste mais une vie pas simple et pas
facile en Tchécoslovaquie vous lancez
dans le ski et d'ailleurs ça vous a
beaucoup appris le ski parce que ça vous
a pris la ténacité parce que vous dites
quand on descend une montagne sur deux
bouts de bois ben ça vous apprend à
compter que que sur vous-même et c'est
peut-être ça qui a forgé votre votre
caractère si solide
c'est vrai
alors la fin des études secondaires vous
tombez amoureuse d'un garçon qui est un
grand skieur check qui s'appelle George
sirop vaca qui est à l'époque étudiant
et puis là vous commencez quand même à
faire des photos vous allez à Prague à
l'université Charles vous commencez à
faire des photos de mode dans modaque
l'éducation puis après je ski et bien
sûr pour l'équipe nationale
tchécoslovaque et puis je gagnais un
petit peu d'argent à côté comme je
pouvais mais dans le monde de la mode en
effet on est dans mannequin suivi
difficile parce qu'il y avait pas on
n'avait pas le droit de se teindre les
cheveux il y a pas de teinture il y a
pas de cinéma il y a pas de discothèque
enfin c'était quand même une une vie
assez contexte ça je peux vous dire il y
en avait et alors un jour vous émigrez
au Canada et vous rejoignez donc votre
fiancée de l'époque qui s'appelait
Georges siroprata comme je l'ai dit et
qui lui a ouvert un magasin de ski au
Canada alors vous avez là-bas bon vous
donnez des cours de ski vous travaillez
dans une agence de mannequin à Montréal
et là
bon je sens quelque chose qui va arriver
et là le fric c'est chic un jour vous
êtes dans une boîte de nuit à New York
avec une amie vous cherchez une table
vous trouvez pas de table ce personne
vous connaît et le garçon qui vous aide
qui vous aide à trouver une table c'est
Donald Trump j'ai senti une masse mon
épaule puis j'aime pas trop ça alors
j'ai regardé derrière moi il y avait ce
type absolument superbe et il m'a dit je
m'appelle donochappe et il m'a dit vous
avez du mal à trouver une table alors
j'ai regardé j'ai regardé mon ami et
puis je lui ai dit on a les bonnes
nouvelles et une mauvaise nouvelle elle
m'a dit c'est quoi la Bonne Nouvelle
allez bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on va voir
une table très très vite parce que ce
monsieur là il connaît bien le
restaurant la mauvaise nouvelle c'est
que il va venir s'asseoir avec nous et
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré
avec vous et votre ami et en quelques
mois plus tard vous signez votre premier
contrat prénuptial et après vous êtes
marié avec lui d'ailleurs c'est vrai que
vous avez signé un contrat par an un
contrat de mariage par an il y avait des
contrats très rapprochés je comprends
pas ont changé les contrats nous n'ont
pas tous les ans peut-être tous les cinq
ou six ans ont changé les contrats c'est
beau l'amour et alors j'ai vraiment
travaillé beaucoup et je mérite tout ce
que j'ai obtenu après parce que vraiment
tout le monde croit que Ivana est devenu
riche après son divorce avec Donald
Trump et en fait vous travaillez
énormément vous étiez très impliqué dans
les affaires de Donald Trump vous
dirigez un casino Atlantique City qui
était l'un des plus rentables du monde
j'ai diriger le Plaza Athénée à New York
j'ai été élu hôtelière de l'année donc
c'est vrai que c'est oui c'est un peu
énervant toujours de que les gens
pensent que vous êtes devenus riches
seulement après votre divorce alors bon
sur votre histoire d'amour avec Donald
Trump c'est vrai qu'au début bon il
avait des aventures ou ferme un petit
peu les yeux au début vous faites ce
qu'on appelle en France la politique de
l'autruche jusqu'au moment du divorce la
crue que son mari était fidèle tout le
temps à elle vous étiez au courant quand
même de l'aventure de votre mari avec
Marla Maple vous étiez au courant
je savais pas j'étais pas au courant je
ne savais pas je l'ai découvert
le soir de Noël à Aspen dans un resto on
était en train de skier c'était
de famille et quand j'ai appris qu'il
avait une liaison avec une autre femme
et notamment ce qui est un respect moi
j'ai trouvé ça horrible et quand j'ai
découvert la liaison j'ai immédiatement
demandé le divorce bon je vais peut-être
un petit peu bourgeoise un petit peu
traditionaliste et pour moi ça a tout
était cassé vous voyez et ça pouvait pas
continuer on est tous différents Massimo
lui il peut continuer et recommencer
recommencer moi pas peut-être que les
choses sont différentes entre les hommes
et les femmes je ne sais pas
je les proches toujours à Evana d'être
trop bourgeoise dans sa mentalité et là
des choses très très strictes
parce que c'est vrai ce qu'on raconte
dans la presse et nous le dire c'est que
vous êtes donc dans ce restaurant au
moment de Noël à Aspen et que dans la
mapulse arrive dans le restaurant
s'approche de vous et vous dit j'aime
votre mari c'est vrai ça
oui oui c'est vrai
exactement ce qui s'est passé si vous
l'avez appris de Noël
donc c'était pas très agréable et alors
là évidemment vous commencez à parler
divorce vous dites je le laisse partir
mais ça va lui coûter cher alors vous
avez un petit peu le problème aussi
qu'il y a eu c'est que à cette époque-là
tu l'as voulu tu vas l'avoir
est-ce que c'est vrai qu'il vous a donné
ces testicules en boucle d'oreille
seulement des diamants seulement des
diamants mon gars alors 14 14 millions
de 14 millions de dollars un appartement
à New York une maison à Mara Lago enfin
ça va quoi et alors là après cette
histoire vous dites je vais pas me
laisser emporter vous dites je vais pas
me laisser
emporter dans le tourbillon du désespoir
vous décidez de vous battre
non je vais pas me coucher et mourir
c'est exactement ce qui s'est passé moi
j'ai une vie c'est merveilleux je vais
pas me laisser mourir et ma conviction
c'est qu'il faut pas regarder le passé
le passé mais il est fini c'est terminé
il faut regarder vers l'avenir ça c'est
la première vengeance c'est que vous
avez gagné 10 fois ce qui vous avez
donné lors du lors du divorce mais
surtout lui avec Marla Maple il se marie
avec elle et il divorce combien de temps
après
finalement
tout est bien qui finit bien n'est-ce
pas
alors c'est beaucoup d'argent on évalue
votre fortune je sais pas si c'est vrai
à 45 millions de dollars vous avez
combien de maisons Ivana
yacht qui s'appelle le Ivana
vous dites finalement combien de steaks
est-ce qu'on peut manger dans une
journée alors quand on est riche on
mange combien de steaks par jour
quand on est riche combien on mange de
steaks
qui sont vraiment obsédés de faire de
l'argent et encore de l'argent et
toujours de l'argent
des millionnaires des millionnaires des
trillionaires ils travaillent ils font
rien que travailler jamais ils ont le
temps pour leur famille leurs enfants et
c'est simplement pour gagner de l'argent
alors combien de steaks en effet
pouvez-vous manger par jour combien de
voitures vous pouvez conduire en même
temps combien de maisons dans combien de
maisons pouvez-vous vivre en même temps
il faut s'arrêter et puis se détendre un
petit peu on n'a jamais vu un
coffre-fort suivre un corbillard alors
Serge maintenant je voudrais poser à
ivana Trump la question qui tue
alors ivana Trump
question importante si demain matin
Donald Trump revenait vers vous et vous
proposez de reprendre la vie de famille
avec vos enfants il en oublie tout on se
remet ensemble tous et on reprend une
vie normale tu me pardonnes excuse-moi
est-ce que vous seriez d'accord est-ce
que vous lui diriez oui ou non
[Musique]
et j'en suis vraiment convaincu d'abord
parce que je suis amoureuse d'un autre
homme et puis il y a eu tellement de mal
qui a été fait bon bien sûr j'ai
surmonté et maintenant les enfants ont
réussi à atteindre la stats de paix
paisible et moi je veux continuer avec
ma vie et puis Donald a des intérêts qui
sont différents moi j'ai des intérêts
différents je passe beaucoup de temps en
Europe je jouis de ma vie je fais des
choses différentes et lui il continue à
travailler travailler pour fabriquer ces
milliards et c'est pas fait pour moi ce
n'est plus fait pour moi non aucun
espoir on rallume
voilà
le flic c'est sick alors maintenant on
va passer une petite interview Ivana
très sympathique c'est un petit jeu
c'est pas sans importance
interview alerte rose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien quel est ivana Trump votre première
pensée quand vous vous trouvez en phase
d'un homme séduisant
on a envie de le tenir dans ses bras et
puis le troisième chose je vais pas vous
dire
dans ses bras
mais je vous dis pas la troisième quel
est pour vous le quel est pour vous il
va m'apprendre
le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
sur la plage entre les rochers
attention attention
est-ce que vous préférez draguer ou vous
faire draguer
on sait toujours l'homme qui doit me
draguer d'accord
c'est ça qui c'est ça qui leur plaît aux
hommes
ils aiment travailler pour venir vous
chercher est-ce que vous préférez
larguer ou vous faire larguer
embrasser ou qu'on vous embrasse
mais j'aime bien embrasser j'aime bien
j'ai changé
est-ce que vous conservez un fantasme
inavouable
bien sûr
et je ne vais pas l'admettre je vais pas
me confesser est-ce que vous croyez que
tout le monde a des fantasmes et ses
fantasmes et bien il reste à l'intérieur
de vous faut pas de vivre tous vos
fantasmes non vous trouvez ça plus sexy
de les garder en vous plutôt que de les
vivre
à quoi reconnaissez-vous la passion qui
s'éteint
la personne
si on parle d'une véritable relation
bien sûr
[Musique]
moins de faire l'amour au lieu de le
faire tous les jours on le fait tous les
deux jours
ou bien tous les jours
qui se fait couper les cheveux qui fait
des choses différentes de ce qui fait
d'habitude il y a des signes qui font
qu'on sait qu'un homme a une liaison par
exemple il rentre tard à la maison bon
c'est pas ce qui m'est arrivé à moi vous
êtes de bons conseils merci merci Madame
frappe
voici donc maintenant un bel homme voici
Charles Berling
bonsoir bonsoir bon je crois que je
crois que Laurent vous êtes occupé pour
la soirée là
soyez sage alors vraiment je vous
demande d'être sage de vous arrêter de
vous arrêter Charles Berling bonsoir
bonsoir vous appelez Charles François
Philibert Berling
vous êtes né à Saint-Mandé donc
permettre ça Marine nationale et puis
après a quitté la marine mais au départ
il était dans la Marine nationale c'est
ce que ça veut dire Baffie Berling
un spécialiste de la zoologie non juste
un petit animal le Berling mais quoi
quelle famille de la famille des ursidés
sans déconner
je vais vérifier
siècle en France donc vous avez été
révélé au grand public par le film de
Patrice Leconte ridicule mais en fait ce
que les gens savent pas où savent mal en
tous les cas si vous aviez beaucoup
travaillé avant vous avez commencé par
le théâtre vous avez commencé à faire du
théâtre à l'âge de 15 ans
au lycée faut dire que votre frère était
metteur en scène quand même mais oui non
c'est pas pour ça enfin c'est à dire mon
frère était aussi dans ce lycée c'était
un lycée à Toulon qui avait un foyer il
y avait du théâtre moi je faisais tout
le temps imbécile donc on m'a conseillé
d'y aller j'y suis allé donc vous vous
êtes à Toulon d'encre au départ
effectivement vous commencez et puis un
jour vous décidez de couper de quitter
Toulon et vous partez en Belgique parce
que vous dites qu'à Toulon quand on
faisait du théâtre ça revenait à dire
qu'on était [ __ ] ouais et alors
je sais pas c'était c'était très mal
considéré parce que là-bas quand on dit
quelqu'un est un [ __ ] ça veut dire que
c'est un con quoi
c'était le cas c'était le cas en tous
les cas donc Charles Berling quitte
Toulon va en Belgique alors vous allez
pas à Paris parce que vous avez peur du
conservatoire et alors Charles Berling
va l'Institut National Supérieur des
Arts et Spectacles donc qui était
accepté à Bruxelles ça non ça existe
encore c'est une école à Bruxelles de
cinéma et théâtre donc là vous commencez
le théâtre et très rapidement très
rapidement vous avec les mirabelles non
c'est vrai
c'est un Savignon les mirabelles c'était
une troupe de de travestis
les mirabelles c'était oui c'était super
parce que faire du théâtre pour passer
pour un plaisir c'est vachement beau
cette histoire
ils m'ont dit tu veux pas jouer avec
nous alors moi j'ai dit pourquoi pas
j'ai lu le texte j'ai rien compris à la
pièce j'aurais dit je peux pas jouer
avec vous j'ai rien compris alors ils
m'ont dit bah ça fait rien quand même à
la fête alors j'y suis allé à la fête
puis j'ai trouvé les mecs super sympa et
maintenant toute sa vie chaque fois
qu'il sera interviewé à l'ital et on lui
parlera des mirabelles donc alors vous
avez fait beaucoup de terres c'était
bien on avait décidé
théâtre et après des films donc Nelly et
Monsieur Arnaud c'est un des premiers
films importants ridicule nettoyage à
sec
c'était très intéressant je sais pas si
vous avez vu ce film nettoyage à sec
c'est l'histoire s'il y avait un film
d'Anne Fontaine avec Miou-Miou Mathilde
Seigner Stanislas Merah c'est un petit
couple de teinturier en province et un
jour il tombe sur deux barjots qui sont
Mathilde Seigner et qu'il les dévergonde
complètement c'est ça
Mumu est une espèce de Madame Bovary qui
est complètement fasciné par les deux
personnages en question et vous avez des
petites moustaches dans le film comme ça
puis vous suivez votre femme quoi ça
vous gêne un peu et vous finirez dans
une va vous faire [ __ ] oui bon on est
au cinéma à partir direction
les journalistes à l'époque vous
demandez c'était dur de se faire [ __ ]
quand vous avez fait le film
pose cette question
m'a dit que c'était désagréable beaucoup
c'est une jouissance mais il y a une
chose importante c'est que vous ça vous
a fait prendre conscience de votre côté
parce que quand même c'est pas rien
cette scène non plus ça vous a fait
prendre conscience de ce côté petit
bourgeois non mais c'est vrai de votre
côté un peu étriqué disons mais non mais
c'est ça que je disais c'est à dire
plutôt que de regarder ça vous feriez
bien de vous poser la difficulté du rôle
c'était de se voir en peine à jouir
voilà voilà c'est ça le problème ce qui
était ce qui était dur pour moi de que
dans ce rôle là c'était c'est que le
type il arrive pas à s'assumer il arrive
pas à s'assumer ça c'est c'est
épouvantable d'être comme ça on a tous
ça en soi donc tout d'un coup on se voit
on voit cette partie là de soi-même
c'est jamais agréable non il y a
d'autres films je ne parle pas de
celui-là il y a ceux qui m'aiment
prendre le train de Patrice Hérault qui
est un film remarquable qui a pas eu le
succès qu'il méritait il y a eu l'ennui
de Cédric Kahn ou ça baisse beaucoup ça
vous êtes à poil dans l'ennui de Cédric
4 vous êtes on voit vos fesses oui même
plus même plus mais j'étais discret même
au-delà alors c'est l'histoire d'un prof
de philo hein qui tombe amoureux d'une
main fête qui jouait par Sophie
Guillemin et qui bascule dans dans
l'obsession complète
je vous ai fait plein de bons films et
finalement c'est vrai on est même pas
sûr que le public vous
sache vraiment qui vous êtes non mais
c'était déjà comme ça au théâtre mais
moi ça me plaît c'est à dire c'est parce
que je pense que je suis un acteur donc
les gens me reconnaissent pas forcément
il me sert pas forcément de rôle en rôle
ils se disent pas forcément tiens c'est
le même quoi mais c'est flatteur j'ai
fait par exemple cet été les Destinées
sentimentales enfin c'est sorti cet été
de Olivier Assayas avec Emmanuel Béart
Isabelle Huppert d'après le roman de
Jacques Charden très grand film failli
avoir le prix d'interprétation à Cannes
vous l'aurez mérité d'ailleurs vous
l'avez pas eu sous la déçu ça oui c'est
la première fois où j'étais déçu de pas
avoir un prix alors pour vous vous dites
les médias sont des ogres qui avalent
tout il faut les utiliser
il faut les utiliser pour amener les
gens à garder mon travail il faut pas
avoir une existence parallèle à celle de
son travail dans les médias en gros
c'est ce que vous dites vous c'est
peut-être pour ça d'ailleurs que on
disait tout à l'heure le public vous
repère mal c'est peut-être parce que
finalement vous vous avez aucune
existence en dehors de votre travail
c'est juste on sait pas avec qui vous
couchez en ce moment par exemple au
bossu on l'a su comment
vous ne savez pas non en ce moment je ne
sais pas non
c'est pas mon travail de toute façon
mais bien sûr non mais c'est vrai vous
êtes très discret blague à part vous
êtes très discret oui mais parce que moi
encore une fois ce qui m'a je crois que
le problème c'est que si on devient une
personnalité publique et qu'on est
connoté comme ça ou comme ça pour jouer
la comédie ça devient de plus en plus
dur moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est de
jouer alors vous êtes de la pâte à
modeler vous voulez être pris ça c'est
vraiment disparaître derrière les rôles
bien sûr bon alors on va mieux vous
connaître
bien alors Charles Berling on s'aperçoit
qu'on vous connaît assez mal en dehors
de vos films évidemment donc pour mieux
vous connaître on va vous faire une art
diviou
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
bien voici Laurent Baffie n'est pas la
semaine prochaine on sera pourquoi
regardez Christine Boisson là-bas
oui ça va j'attends patiemment
je suis très bien oui et vous-même ça va
très bien il finit le monsieur et après
je termine le plombage et après on passe
bien vous vous dites quoi le matin quand
vous voyez devant un miroir ridicule à
qui voulez-vous ressembler quand vous
étiez petit
à personne à moi-même si possible vous
aviez pas d'idole non pas du tout
qu'est-ce qui vous énerve le plus chez
vous chez moi ma façon de marcher j'ai
fait un tour
est trop raide enfin bon c'est très
désagréable
jaloux
qu'est-ce que vous énerve le plus
ça non coiffure et chez moi
ça trop bien coiffure ça veut dire qu'on
se donne du mal il y a pas un jeu qui
bouge ça c'est sûr bien est-ce que vous
seriez prêt à tout quitter pour le grand
amour non
non c'est rare oui en général bah ouais
pas moi si vous restez 24 heures à vivre
vous feriez quoi l'amour c'est nul comme
question parce que non parce que quand
si on sait qu'on a 24 heures à vivre en
continu espérer que ça sera plus long
que ça croyez-moi on dit pas ça on
l'accepte pas j'arrête de poser cette
question alors non alors attendez
Benjamin Castaldi tu notes
mais ça change
quelle est la dernière chose que vous
faites avant de vous coucher
l'amour et quand tu es seul quand je
suis tout seul l'amour non je
mets les dents dans une verre
c'est un peu tu es gentil
alors attention Charles Berling vous
changeriez quoi en vous si vous aviez
une baguette magique
à part le pull
pourquoi il est pas beau s'il est bien
pourquoi non
je disais
pas bien ça marche
j'adore
parce que il faut justifier un quota de
conneries
et oui
vous savez partir sur le petit bateau
et toi dans le bateau et vous faites
toute la côte comme ça d'accord ok parce
qu'il peut attendre 2 minutes vas-y
bosse
surnom quand vous a donné que vous
haïssez
bien on était déjà la question suivante
ou des trucs comme ça je sais pas
oui
[Musique]
le péché qui vous tente le plus
la luxure quoi
la luxure genre
déjà quand j'étais petit on me disait
que j'étais pervers que j'étais machin
ouais on peut devenir copain tous les
deux chats
ce que je sais de vous distiller chez
Stock je vois personne fait les mains on
fait les pieds mais tu le vois pas
mon invité suivant est encore plus rare
à la télévision ces derniers temps que
Pierre Arditi mais il a choisi tout le
monde en parle pour venir parler de son
livre de son premier livre voici Jacques
Dutronc
[Applaudissements]
continu
Jacques Dutronc mesdames messieurs
comment ça va ça va ça va la dernière
fois qu'on s'est vu c'était il y a 10
ans
alors c'était extraordinaire parce
qu'elle a sorti de cette émission de
double jeu on s'était dit mais alors du
tronc il nous fait que des aphories il y
a toutes ces réponses sont des
aphorismes et alors effectivement quand
je dis le bouquin il y en a quand même
pas mal qui était dans l'émission qui
sont dans le livre et j'étais une
reprise de vos interviews j'en ai
retrouvé j'en ai retrouvé pas mal dans
penser réplique je montre à nos amis
voilà pensez réplique on cherche midi
éditeurs zoom zoom zoom mon garçon vous
le faites pas Jacques
c'est quoi ça
c'est possible
vous êtes choqué Audrey
donc du livre de Jacques Dutronc il y a
une phrase qui résume le livre je n'ai
strictement rien à dire mais je tiens à
ce que ça se sache voilà
net et précis alors on a envie
évidemment quand on est ici comme moi ce
soir de lire tout le livre alors
évidemment ça peut pas être possible
vous ne comprenez bien je pourrais pas
dire tous mais bon alors je vais en
citer quelques-unes au fur et à mesure
mais bon alors il y en a une que j'ai
noté qui me fait rigoler c'est je suis
toujours à l'heure à mes rendez-vous
comme ça je peux partir plus vite
quand on vous demande vous buvez pour
noyer votre ennui vous répondez non pour
l'irriguer seulement et alors votre
grande phrase une plus grande phrase la
vie est une maladie mortelle
transmissible sexuellement
il y a aussi il y a aussi le cancer
guéri du cigare
j'ai arrêté de croire au Père Noël le
jour où dans une galerie marchande il
m'a demandé un autographe voilà quoi
c'est que des trucs comme ça les cafés
je suis très fidèle quand je fais
l'ouverture je fais aussi la fermeture
que j'aime bien on va parler de votre
vie Jacques ça va être un peu long parce
que c'est pas tout jeune non plus mais
bon alors on y va
vous souvenez d'Alain Barrière vous en
souvenez d'Alain Barrière bien sûr bien
alors vous êtes né dans un quart de
police en 1943
c'était le couvre-feu en 43 et de
bombardements alliés vous êtes né dans
un quart de police voilà ce qui fait
qu'après j'ai été déclaré la mairie du
17e voilà et après avec votre ami
Gainsbourg quand vous étiez ramassé par
des quarts de police en fin de nuit bien
après finalement ça vous changeait pas
beaucoup puisque vous étiez né dans un
quart de but
de redevenir enfin c'était c'était ça
mais le but Serge ne le savais pas lui
mais enfin le but c'était ça je revenais
dans l'enfance position fœtal était
ingénieur des pensées mais pseudo le
seigneur des mines c'était un faux parce
qu'ils ont été musicien amateur et c'est
vrai il y a déjà le sens de la fantaisie
propre du tronc un master et devrait
il aimait beaucoup la musique bien sûr
même il jouait incognito avec un phone
et souvent pour ça que la plupart des on
appelait ça les dactylo aller dans les
mêmes balles vers la Bastille donc pour
pas reconnaître
leur taulier entre guillemets c'est mon
père mettait des faux nets où il se
déguisait avec je sais pas quoi enfin
les moustaches
les personnes se détapissent il a joué
pendant 50 ans il avait un truc comme
vous ce qui fumait beaucoup il y a une
phrase dans le livre sur lui vous dites
ça doit faire 70 ans qu'il fume quand il
est se bénisse et la planche pour
pouvoir fumer et ma mère l'appelait le
remorqueur c'est génial quand même mais
c'est vrai
il avait il avait une habitude aussi
votre père qui était là aussi vous avez
hérité beaucoup de votre père il
balançait des pets énormes à table
il était à côté d'une jolie femme il
balançait un pen énorme et il disait ne
vous inquiétez pas je dirais que c'est
moi d'ailleurs
et oui
l'enfance du jeune Dutronc
bon l'école ça vous motivait pas
spécialement non vous aviez des
rhumatismes c'est vrai c'est vrai
de mon excuse elle disait c'était comme
je vous l'ai dit il y a deux jours mon
fils a rechuté était dans le coup votre
mère oui c'était ça plutôt les chutes
dans l'escalier
l'école à ces jeunes et vous entrez dans
une école de dessin industriels mais
votre vrai vocation c'était le
vétérinaire comme tous les mots quoi par
cycliste ou quoi vous avez vu
le faire
donc vous aviez 200 souris non
à peu près
j'ai changé puisque j'ai 44 chats
maintenant
j'en ai acheté d'autres ou je sais pas
quoi donc il y a des combats énormes
entre famille de souris donc faut
qu'elle se sente toutes les parfumé
l'autre colonne donc elle se
reconnaissait à l'autre Cologne donc
tout ça s'arrangeait tranquillement sans
bagarre alors à l'époque vous rogiez
beaucoup hein parce que vous y êtes pas
grand chose j'ai des boulevards des
Italiens aussi nush vous écoutiez les
camelots sur les grands boulevards ça
vous plaisait ça il y avait le père la
souris je sais pas si vous avez connu
qu'est-ce qu'il vendait mais une souris
une fois de plus non mais qui était tenu
par espèce de petit fil et il faisait
peur
parce que je découvre que d'avoir du
tronc était au lycée Condorcet qui était
très loin de lui c'est Jacques Decourt
dans le même âge donc on mettrait dans
les mêmes quartiers que je faisais aussi
les grands boulevards je me souviens
très bien du père la souris avec les
mots d'excuse de la mère du Dutron
ressemble beaucoup au mot d'excuse de la
mienne
vous avez en commun aussi d'aimer
beaucoup les chats et d'avoir essayé de
fumer le cigare
c'est ce soir voilà
bien alors donc en fait votre vrai
passion Jacques Dutronc c'était la
musique et alors à la Trinité au Square
de la Trinité alors là c'est
extraordinaire ça aussi c'est un peu
comme votre histoire il y a des choses
comme ça imaginez que dans ce square de
la Trinité brio c'est le score de la
Trinité il y avait Jacques Dutronc qui
traînait il y avait Johnny Hallyday qu'à
l'époque s'appelait jean-Philippe Smet
il y avait dit Mitchell non
à l'époque vous imaginez que dans ce
petit square de la Trinité comme ça les
mecs qui jouaient qui étaient ados c'est
des gens qui sont devenus parmi les
chanteurs les plus les plus connus dans
les dans les 10 ans suivant quoi
c'est marrant ça quand même c'était un
nid de talent c'est rigolo ça alors vous
faites un premier groupe qui s'appelle
les Tritons
peut-être je sais plus moi et puis après
si vous connaissez le taureau les
cyclones quand même oui vous étiez pas
le taureau vous ah non je devais être le
guitariste de faire partie d'un des
cyclones mais j'ai joué avec Michel
surtout longtemps après au départ je
jouais que Johnny on avait fait un
espèce de groupe pas mal il était
comment génial à l'époque est-ce qu'on
sentait qu'il avait vraiment ce
potentiel
ça se sentait bien sûr
un jour Jacques Dutronc on peut le dire
je crois parce que maintenant il y a
prescription vous fiancez
la dernière minute tout était prêt
c'est vrai et il va voir la famille il
leur dit bah non je vais pas épouser
votre fille et les gens ils croyaient
que c'était une plaisanterie
j'espère que
ils ont enfin compris j'espère
maintenant
elle attend encore
alors ils ont dit les beaux-parents
quand il leur a dit ça il est drôle ton
mari
c'était quand même à l'époque on disait
vous savez je fais de la musique et
c'est ça où je chante je ne sais quoi
c'est où je fais j'essaie de jouer la
comédie ou je sais pas quoi mais
qu'est-ce que vous faites à part ça
c'était vraiment cette époque là ensuite
Jacques Dutronc on part en Allemagne
comme Johnny Hallyday comme Elvis
Presley il était de bon temps à l'époque
de faire son service militaire en
Allemagne quand on voulait devenir une
rockstar et au retour donc Michelle les
pirates les champions vous devenez
directeur artistique assistant
directement artistique chez Vogue et là
vous commencez à écrire des chansons et
en 65 vous rencontrez Jacques Lanzmann
quelle époque en chef de lui
collaboration extrêmement fructueuse
évidemment puisque vous avez fait parmi
les plus grandes chansons françaises les
plus classiques en tous les cas et puis
comme vous trouvez personne pour les
chanter vous décidez de les chanter vous
quoi oui oui c'est pas venu tout de
suite ça non non j'ai chanté ça tout à
fait en touriste
puis je me suis retrouvé à la canne
devant des caméras je me suis retrouvé à
la télévision
j'ai dit autant continuer maintenant oui
ça vous a pris comme ça quoi sursaut
c'est pour ça que vous avez jamais eu
l'air d'y croire en fait parce qu'au
départ ça vous est tombé non vous êtes
victime un peu du syndrome parce que
j'appellerai le syndrome Julien Clerc
c'est-à-dire que Julien Clerc il a fait
des mélodies formidables il a écrit des
mélodies extraordinaires on parle
toujours de ces paroles liés bon
remarquerez on parle de Maurice vallée
on parle de rodaji on parle de Dabadie
maintenant on parle de Carla Bruni bon
on oublie simplement que Julien Clerc
toutes les chansons qu'il a chanté c'est
en général lui qui les a composé mais du
transparent on a beaucoup parlé de
lanzman on a dit les paroles formidable
et tout là la façon d'interpréter avec
cette distance se recule que vous aviez
et en fait les musiques c'est vous qui
les avez faites donc c'est un bon
compositeur
bon sûrement compositeur
qu'est-ce qu'il dit c'est l'art d'être
loué deux fois ouais te dire quelqu'un
vous êtes charmant mais non mais
six mois
[Applaudissements]
mon mal de tête mon plateau
[Musique]
ça c'est un truc regarde Audrey
[Applaudissements]
il y a les playboys de profession habité
par Cardin et chauffez pas
[Musique]
déroule en Ferrari à la place
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Jean Balthazar je me le dis
je sais caster tu me les vies
j'aime les filles on voit c'est parti
[Musique]
je suis pour le caméli je suis pour le
socialisme et pour le décapitalisme
parce que je suis comporte Paris
[Musique]
toute ma vie j'ai rêvé l'être une autre
aise
c'est le plus grand le plus charmant le
plus élégant avec ses gants ou bien
sanguin alors saine
quand il s'amène quand il c'était un
petit jardin qui sentait bon le
métropolitain
il est sympa et attirant
méfiez-vous c'est un truand Jacques
Dutronc
qu'est-ce que honnêtement quand vous
entendez ça vous fait quel effet vous
dites c'est plus moi aujourd'hui ou
qu'est-ce que c'est bien mais c'est bien
c'est les anciens si vous êtes contents
ou ça vous fait chier entendre ça
va vous êtes tellement oui comment vous
êtes quoi on a toujours envie de vous
faire plaisir j'ai envie de vous voir
sourire
et personne d'autre Marnay Catherine
barman me demande de vous demander si
vous aimez les chansons de Jacques
Dutronc
en plus il y a un truc extraordinaire
c'est devenu l'idole des jeunes à un
moment avec un personnage très décalé
parce qu'ils avaient tous les cheveux
longs évidemment et vous allez les
cheveux courts un petit costard un peu
un peu étriqué vous aviez pas d'opinion
politique à l'époque tout le monde était
pour la période vous vous étiez vous en
foutiez de ça c'était pas par
provocation des autres c'est que grâce à
la chanson les playboys j'ai été habillé
à l'oeil j'avais des pompes de chez
Carville j'avais des réductions
absolument partout chez Fauchon je vous
en prie c'était pas mal à l'époque on
peut dire une chose c'est que vous êtes
un peu années 50 c'est à dire votre
style d'humour votre façon d'être ça
fait plus penser aux années 50 que que
non mais c'est pas un reproche dans les
années 50 parce que regardez les
canulars que vous faisiez par exemple
les regarde les canular c'était des
canulars très années 50 je sais pas il y
avait un canular qui consistait à piquer
les pompes du
mecs elle lui a acheté les mêmes en plus
petit
donc le lendemain le mec ouvrez la porte
il prenait ses pompes elles avaient
quatre tailles de moi si tu veux essayer
de les mettre il pensait que ses pieds
avaient gonflé parce qu'à chaque fois il
y avait toujours un mec à lui faire un
pote du représentant qui disait c'est le
chauffage par le sol ça fait gonfler les
pieds je sais pas il y avait tout le
temps
et puis il y en avait un autre aussi
c'était de mettre un étron énorme dans
un papier journal tout le monde l'a fait
moi de mettre le feu au papier journal
le mec sortait de la oh il donnait un
grand coup de pied évidemment dans le
papier
alors un jour je vous ai demandé la plus
grande joie de votre carrière et vous
m'avez dit parce que je posais déjà les
mêmes questions comme tout le monde peut
s'en apercevoir et c'est pour ça que je
n'ai pas changé et c'est pour et vous
m'avez répondu c'est le jour où j'ai eu
un gala annulé à 8h je suis rentré dans
un hôtel pourri pour lire les Pieds
Nickelés voilà c'était la plus grande
joie de sa carrière et la plus grande
déception la plus grande déception vous
m'avez répondu c'était d'essayer de me
masturber avec les pieds nickelés ça
c'est dur c'est très très j'ai
l'impression parce qu'ils sont trois
peut-être
alors bon après vous avez eu un avec
lanzman je crois qu'il y a eu des
problèmes j'en sais rien mais enfin
disons vous êtes moins vu vous êtes
moins travaillé ensemble et vous êtes
retrouvés
il y a quelques années grâce à moi parce
que j'avais organisé 40 ans de 45 tours
c'était les meilleurs 45 tours des 40
dernières années évidemment le gagnant
ça a été il est 5h par ici parce qu'il
est absolument normal parmi toutes les
chansons de d'après-guerre justement et
ce jour-là ben vous êtes retrouvés j'ai
pas beaucoup revu par la suite mais
enfin au moins on a eu le plaisir de
vous revoir ensemble
je cherche une paire de moustaches
[Applaudissements]
un jour ou deux et je lui ai dit c'est
Jacques Dutroux il m'a dit lequel parce
que il m'a dit ça fait trois fois qu'on
m'appelle en disant c'est du tronc
j'ai été presque à faire comme
l'histoire la fameuse histoire d'Enrico
Macias et du chantier au téléphone
quelque chose dans un magazine qui se
vend librement vous avez déclaré il y a
quelques semaines Jacques lanzman que
vous seriez prêt aujourd'hui à faire un
à faire un nouvel album pour et avec
Jacques Dutronc
sûrement parce que je pense qu'on a
beaucoup de choses à dire ensemble et
que
je suis sûr qu'on peut faire quelque
chose de bien et ça ne sera pas très
très difficile parce que c'est pas la
peine de refaire ce qu'on a fait ce qui
est intéressant c'est de faire c'est
qu'on a envie de faire maintenant quoi
on a envie de chanter il y a tellement
changé physiquement en plus je trouve
super à mon avis
vous avez envie de chanter c'est même
pas une question de flemme c'est il faut
faut en avoir envie quoi faut bon mais
bon je peux pas faire de milliards de
choses à la fois je veux dire bon il y
en a qui baisent et qui fument en même
temps d'autres qui fument après c'est
tout merci
on applaudit Jacques Dutronc
jacobsman et Jean-Luc Delarue c'était
donc 40 ans de 45 tours et chansons
meilleur des 40 ans il est 5h Paris
s'éveille voilà bien alors en 73 on fait
toute votre vie là
on est en 73 oh [ __ ] on est pas rendu
ah bah c'est plus long que la ville de
Audrey Marnay vous prenez prétexte de la
naissance de votre fils pour dire ben je
vais m'occuper de lui c'est une bonne
excuse pour arrêter la scène quoi en
fait je n'ai fait ni l'un ni l'autre
[Rires]
femme c'est plutôt Françoise qui s'est
occupé de Thomas oui alors au cinéma au
cinéma vous êtes génial tout de suite
premier film Sébastien et puis ensuite
piala enfin il y en a eu d'autres mais
je cite piala Van Gogh parce que ça a
été quand même un événement vous dites
en parlant de piala pour justement on en
revient à ce qu'on dit tout à l'heure
pour le vexer il faut le flatter
voilà et alors il y a un truc très sympa
dans ce film c'est qu'à un moment vous
il avait écrit vous êtes avec
Mademoiselle Gachet la fille du docteur
gâcher dans la voiture dans Van Gogh et
à un moment il y avait cinq pages de
texte et c'est pas que vous avez pas
voulu les apprendre c'est que vous avez
réduit vous avez transformé les 5 pages
de texte en un regard
c'est par fainéanti sûrement mais je
crois pas c'est
vrai que j'étais pas
très convaincu de ces cinq pages en tout
cas vous avez dit il faut connaître le
texte pour se permettre de pas le dire
oui bien alors vous êtes tourné aussi
avec Godard vous dites c'est comme un
psy mais c'est lui qui paye et puis
alors le pire c'est Spielberg alors ça
c'est incroyable moi si j'avoue là je
vous comprends pas un jour Steven
Spielberg demande à Jacques dit je
voudrais vous voir c'est ça c'était
pourquoi le film c'était Indiana Jones
oui je crois que c'était que vous soyez
Indiana Jones je ne sais pas mais je
parle très mal l'anglais donc
Spielberg rencontre du tronc et lui dit
j'aimerais que vous jouiez Indiana Jones
et je sais pas vous avez dit beaucoup de
conneries pendant le déjeuner quand même
non sûrement parce que vous a jamais
rappelé quoi euh non bonsoir
Jean-Marie messieurs mesdames messieurs
pour applaudir
bien
et puis alors après bon bah vous
rencontrez alors Françoise Hardy bon
elle vient souvent ici on s'est à peu
près comment ça se passe chez vous donc
je vais pas vous poser beaucoup de
questions parce que c'est tout en parler
tout à l'heure de l'amour fusionnel
Audrey ce qu'il faut être comme ça
toujours coller l'un sur l'autre et ce
marché sur les pieds dans la salle de
bain ou est-ce qu'il faut prendre un peu
de distance pour conserver du mystère du
fantasme en Jacques puis la résolu le
problème une fois pour toute ils vivent
enfin un état chacun c'est ça voilà et
ça dure parce que tous ces couples du
showbize ils ont tous divorcé sauf le
vôtre c'est vrai regardez Johnny et
Sylvie
et quand on vous dit quand on vous dit
ça fait 30 ans que vous vivez avec
Françoise Hardy vous dites on vous dit
ça fait 30 ans de vie commune et vous
répondez 30 ans de vie peu commune mais
pas inventé c'est là
puis quand on vous parle d'elle est-ce
que moi je vous ai demandé d'ailleurs
c'est moi qui ai demandé quel don de la
nature voudriez avoir vous avez dit j'ai
déjà le doigt vert le pouce vert la
queue verte
et je suis marié avec une belle plante
alors il y a un truc où on va peut-être
pas être tout le temps d'accord c'est
immovrini vous savez qu'ici quand
quelqu'un parle trop quand quelqu'un
parle trop il est mosaïkais et on lui
diffuse un petit morceau d'immovrini
vous c'est vos potes ils m'ouvrent
c'est bien non mais
oui
évidemment avec une fausse barbe et une
perruque mais
Gildas sur les autographes
bon alors votre maison encore ça va vous
êtes toujours là-bas vous êtes
tranquille vos chats vos potes hein
c'est vrai que vous parlez aux chats
puis quand il y a quelqu'un qui arrive
dans le chemin il fait comme ça comme
avec son portable pour faire croire
qu'il parlait parce que je fais semblant
de téléphone
alors je vous ai demandé à l'époque
comment vous avez fait pour vous faire
accepter par les corps si vous avez
répondu rien justement
la situation politique en Corse vous y
intéressez un petit peu non non vous en
foutez quoi non je m'en fous pas mais de
là je suis intéressé
s'intéressait déjà pas à la politique il
y a 30 ans et encore pas du tout
maintenant
une belle phrase sur le travail vous
dites ça paye dans le futur le
travailleur que la paresse ça paye
content
alors vous vivez de la vous avez la
retraite de la SACEM je savais pas ça
ouverte une retraite la SACEM bien sûr
je suis retraité Vous êtes à la retraite
alors vous dites je suis ni riche ni
bien portant
toujours
c'est vrai vous le savez
en disant
je suis content de vous voir oui c'est
pour ça que j'ai dit il me faudra mettre
sur ma tombe encore encore
non mais c'est vrai tous les journaux
toutes les télés on va tenir au prêtre
pourtant vous buvez plus là c'est un
petit peu
pourtant j'ai demandé mais tu veux quoi
j'ai demandé c'est parti vous dites je
sais pas pourquoi j'ai arrêté de boire
le jour où j'ai arrêté de boire je vais
te bourré
c'est une analyse d'urine ça
Jacques Dutronc on va faire l'anti
portrait chinois vous connaissez le
portrait chinois bah si le portrait
chinois je vous dis si tu étais si
c'était une fleur si vous étiez une
fleur et vous me dites j'espère une rose
bonté portrait chinois c'est autre chose
on ne bouge pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si vous étiez une rupture
lévrisme
pourquoi pas c'est rapide une injure va
[ __ ] le conte tes morts qui t'a chié
de la souventerie un maudite des quatre
serpents
si vous étiez une maladie
incurable de toute façon
dans la grippe parce que ça met les gens
à plat
un accident
travail bien sûr c'est une perversion
parler de soi-même à la troisième
personne comme Alain Delon
il y a des plombiers aussi
faire l'alcool les femmes les femmes ça
va ensemble non
une arme
un pistolet à eau
un supplice
je vais pas répondre chinois mais
le Monopoly
[Rires]
moi j'aurais répondu l'astrologie moi
maintenant c'est une routine si vous
étiez un dictateur
je remetter en scène si vous étiez une
torture
à la torture Jean-Pierre Foucault voilà
merci
bien et maintenant
voici le petit du tronc madame monsieur
alors c'est fou un vrai coup de vieux
parce que c'est comme Drucker si tu veux
dire que j'ai vu les parents maintenant
je commence à voir les enfants le jour
il y aura les enfants de Thomas Dutronc
dans mon émission je serai vraiment très
très vieux qui fait des interviews
Gaston qui a bientôt faire des
interviews parce que si tu dois je peux
pas là je prends un vrai coup de vieux
ce soir ça va
alors donc Thomas Dutronc est le fils de
Jacques Dutronc et de Françoise Hardy
évidemment des parents exceptionnels
qu'on aime beaucoup ici bien alors
Thomas vous êtes à l'affiche de
confession d'un dragueur qui est un film
d'Alain Soral d'après son propre livre
vous savez comment on fait
très bien alors bon l'histoire vous
appelez Paul vous êtes un provincial un
peu intello et timide
qui va à Paris pour faire Sciences Po et
puis qui dit dans le jardin Luxembourg
voilà et il suit une fille une
après-midi suit une fille et il
rencontre un dénommé Fab qui est joué
par Saïd qui lui montre comment emballer
les gonzesses
qui sautent la fille vous vous attendez
en bas le mec qui va sauter la fille et
il vous propose de vous initier à la
drague alors le personnage vous vous
reconnaissez en lui le personnage comme
ça un peu un peu timide intello non non
c'était composition alors
vous avez quand même un petit peu de
timidité un peu de réserve en vous non
ouais surtout ce soir peut-être mais non
mais ça va églantine détendez mon ami
bien il y a quand même une espèce
d'homosexualité sous-jacente entre les
deux personnages non c'est vrai c'est
vrai vous êtes aperçu de ça en faisant
le film elle sousjasse non mais c'est
refait
alors si votre si votre premier rôle
mais en fait vous avez déjà fait un film
vous étiez dans le derrière de Valérie
Lemercier qui vient exceptionnel je dis
à chaque fois que je peux le dire vous
étiez pas très chaud au départ pour
faire le film là il a fallu qu'il
n'insiste pas mal à l'un Soral comme ça
c'est bien j'étais couvert quoi c'est
toi qui l'auras voulu moi je freine mon
mieux parce que je suis un garçon
fasse un timide non c'est ça
c'est un échange de bon procédés qui a
lieu insisté j'ai dit bon bah ok tant
pis je le fais moi c'est bien de faire
du cinéma
il est aussi décidé que son père il a
dit ouais c'est pas mal ouais ouais je
vais le faire ouais ouais ouais
plutôt bon
non mais je mets en soi
de Thomas dans un endroit très privé
l'été dernier encore et je peux
témoigner que c'est un très bon musicien
et c'était génial alors d'abord il a
écrit pour son père en 95 ensuite dans
le dernier CD de Salvador vous jouez sur
l'album de votre mère vous avez joué
avec Jacques Naud là vous êtes fort
c'est en jazz manouche avec Romane qui
est un célèbre guitariste manouche
vous avez joué le soir comme ça
c'est des grands amis moi je suis fan de
pour moi de Django Reinhard
j'écoute ça c'est ce qui me sauve de la
tristesse de la vie je sais pas c'est ça
qui me fait approcher les étoiles c'est
d'aller jouer avec les avec les
Manouches
de la musique innée incroyable
alors vous êtes né en 1973 à l'époque où
Jacques Dutronc mettait au cinéma
c'est l'époque où il a fait Antoine et
Sébastien avec Jean-Marie Périer
puis après vous avez une éducation
évidemment assez bipolaire je dirais
quel est son thème
Astro le pauvre
ça marche c'est vrai que ça marche c'est
vrai que ça marche ça nous a
complètement non non je suis assez
réticent mais c'est vrai que à 70% c'est
vrai qu'on retrouve des surtout ce que
j'ai fait c'est que j'ai lu le pour être
sûr il faut lire le contraire en fait on
lit les autres signes et c'est vrai que
finalement le sien ça marche un peu
mieux quand je dis les capricornes je me
rends compte que c'est pas si faux que
ça et comme Françoise et Capricorne en
plus on sait pas c'est énervant mais
c'est vrai donc effectivement éducation
bipolaire c'est à dire votre père disait
c'est un enfant de s'adapter à nous
et votre mère disait c'est aux parents
de s'adapter à l'enfant quelle solution
a été choisie finalement
je crois que il y a des deux en fait
alors lui c'est un père comme du transit
parce que quand c'était Noël par exemple
il avait envie d'avoir ses cadeaux de
Noël et il vient quand le Père Noël et
15 jours avant Noël
évidemment hurler sa mère parce qu'il
disait mais il faut que elle disait il
faut qu'il attende le gosse c'est bien
s'il attend un peu pas du tout il avait
tous ces cadeaux 15 jours avant des
trucs
Françoise vous allez vous faire
comprendre la valeur de l'argent elle
voulait que vous sachiez ce que vaut
l'argent du troncer des billets de 500
balles quoi
donc c'est un peu contradictoire comme
éducation
j'aime bien les choses contrastées
je souhaite à tout le monde
[Musique]
on va faire l'interview par amour
[Applaudissements]
par amour est-ce que vous seriez prêt à
arrêter de jouer de la guitare
et alors ça lui plaît le pauvre
est-ce que vous seriez prêt à cacher le
corps de quelqu'un que je viens de tuer
sans problème
est-ce que vous seriez prêt par amour
arrêter de fumer
par amour est-ce que vous accepteriez
qu'elle est un amant
quand on aime les gens heureux
accepter que j'ai une maîtresse
par amour on est prêt à tout on est prêt
à tout quand on a tous par amour est-ce
que vous seriez prêt à vivre avec ma
maîtresse et moi tous les trois
est-ce qu'elle s'il y a une chatte dans
l'histoire
et vous tiens ça c'était pas dans
l'interview chatte là est-ce que par
amour vous accepteriez que votre Jules
est une maîtresse
je crois pas alors mais si je sais
heureux églantine mais je fais tout pour
qu'il soit heureux
mais c'est bien comme ça vous avez pas
tout le temps
et vous non plus
on va se retrouver sans guitare avec un
chien
par amour Thomas si votre maîtresse moi
si j'étais votre amant peu importe
est-ce que vous seriez prêt à aller tous
les samedis dans un club échangiste
ouais si je peux boire un coup
tranquille
et vous si votre femme vous demande ça
vous le faites
tout de suite
si tu pouvais penser à me le demander tu
vois c'est pas une idée à moi si
vous seriez prêt alors je vais dire moi
puisque apparemment il y a quelque chose
qui se crée entre nous ce soir par amour
est-ce que vous seriez prêt à devenir
mon esclave sexuel comme ça
votre esclave sexuel c'est tout ce que
je vous demande
il est pas très branché
et vous par exemple votre votre Jules
vous dit voilà si tu m'aimes tu deviens
mon esclave sexuel
national interrégional et vert consultez
pas le Conseil national ça prend une
semaine de négo avec les sous-courants
et tout on y arrivera jamais par amour
est-ce que vous prendriez du viagra
nous on n'est pas concernés
par amour est-ce que vous seriez prêt à
vous refaire faire le sexe
comme je joue de la guitare avec mon
sexe c'est un peu délicat pour moi
[Applaudissements]
mourir d'amour vous
tout le monde peut mourir d'amour
j'ai pas de PV j'ai pas de voiture donc
chante le je sais pas
trouve une mélodie toi
quel est le lieu idéal pour une étreinte
un lit ah ouais vous êtes pas
attrapé dans la Safrane
changement de tripes élections
municipales dimanche dernier beaucoup
d'hommes politiques qui ont des
problèmes avec la justice
ou même qui sont toujours en mis en
examen ont gagné ou ont perdu de
justesse c'est le cas de gentil Berry
dans le 5e de Melik monsieur mellik qui
est en tête au premier tour à Béthune
qui a pas été élu mais de d'une
soixantaine de voix François Bernardini
à Istres André la Barrère à Pau
Jean-Jacques de Peretti à Sarlat
Christian Nucci du carrefour de
développement à Beaurepaire Gilles qu'à
toi à Clichy Alain Juppé à Bordeaux
DSK Dominique Strauss-Kahn à Sarcelles
Robert Hue à Montigny-lès-Cormeilles
donc ça fait quand même beaucoup de gens
et certains ont appelé ça à la prime à
la casserole c'est à dire que finalement
le fait d'avoir des problèmes avec la
justice n'a pas empêché tous ces hommes
politiques d'être réélu dimanche et pour
en parler ce soir avec nous l'un des
plus contestés voici Patrick Balkany à
la maison
Patrick Balkany bonsoir Alexandra
Martinez
Eric et Ramzy Michel Bernier vous
connaissez tout le monde donc vous avez
gagné les municipales à Levallois avec 8
points de plus que votre adversaire
Olivier de Chazeau malgré comme je le
disais donc une condamnation à 15 mois
de prison avec sursis et deux ans
d'innigibilité pour avoir employé des
agents de la mairie chez vous à l'époque
vous étiez maire de Levallois employé
des gens qui étaient des salariés de la
mairie dans votre dans votre appartement
et vous avez été reconnu comptable de
fait ce qui veut dire que donc c'est
c'est votre responsabilité et d'ailleurs
vous devez encore vous nous direz ce que
vous en pensez mais vous devez encore
3,4 millions de francs à la commune de
Levallois
en plus de ça vous êtes toujours mis en
examen dans l'affaire des HLM des
Hauts-de-Seine pour trafic d'influence
voilà alors
répondez sur les deux enfin c'est chef
d'accusation déjà d'abord en ce qui
concerne le personnel c'était du
personnel que je prenais effectivement à
la mairie quand je recevais des
investisseurs des gens dont on avait
besoin le Valois c'était pas pour mon
usage personnel car ce que je préfère au
monde c'est me mettre le samedi soir
avec un plateau devant la télé pour
regarder tout le monde en parle voilà
alors
et la faire du trafic d'influence dans
les HLM non vous savez c'est une très
vieille histoire les HLM dès qu'on
parlait d'HLM on mettait tout le monde
en examen alors comme j'étais président
d'un des plus gros offices de France on
m'a mis en examen c'est vrai pour
complicité de trafic je ne sais pas qui
a fait du trafic d'influence et je ne
sais pas de quoi je suis complice mais
il y a très longtemps et j'en ai plus
jamais entendu parler alors donc vous
vous dites je suis blanc comme neige
quoi
j'ai fait une erreur avec le personnel
communal effectivement parce que j'ai
pas pris une délibération
j'aurais municipale vous avez dit vous
pouvez les prendre
exactement je dois dire que ça c'est ma
faute je n'ai pas fait voter une
délibération au Conseil Municipal que
tout le monde aurait bien d'ailleurs
sans problème la prime à la casserole
c'est-à-dire le fait que tous les gens
que j'ai cité là en commençant tout de
suite des problèmes avec la justice et
était réélu ou battu de justesse quoi je
crois que ça n'a rien à voir vous avez
des gens qui sont proches de leur
population qui sont aimés par la
population qui sont de bons mères et
vous en avez qui sont de mauvaises mères
j'ai été pendant 12 ans mère de
Levallois de 83 à 95 exactement ensuite
j'ai eu vacances et
à peu près et mon successeur et bien il
a pas accroché avec la population il a
il a pas eu d'histoire bon il m'a
attaqué Mohame alors ça a pas plus ça a
pas du tout plus haut aux gens et les
Levalloisiens aurait préféré qu'il
s'occupe d'eux plutôt que de s'occuper
de moi moi je me suis toujours occupé
d'eux et c'est ce qu'ils apprécient et
maintenant ils demandent mais que le
maire revienne
est-ce qu'il y a pas un repli local des
gens par rapport à la République des
juges je crois qu'il faut pas
généraliser il faut pas généraliser les
maires sont des gens en général qui sont
très proches de leur population c'est la
catégorie politique la plus aimée en
France vous le voyez dans tous les
sondages les gens aiment bien leur mère
avec les clowns aussi c'est des préférés
des enfants oui oui mais finalement il y
a plus de mer que de clown ça dépend
les mec tu pues Patrick donc vous dites
moi je suis réhabiliter de façon par le
suffrage universel et quand le passé
très simple démocratie quand le préfet
de Hauts-de-Seine conteste votre
élection vous dites c'est insultant pour
celui-là universel absolument quand même
bon vous dites c'est quand même bon il y
a quelqu'un qui a fauté par rapport à la
société s'il est élu au suffrage
universel ça efface sa faute non quand
vous avez fauté c'est comme votre permis
de conduire quand on vous l'enlève pour
un mois on vous l'enlève pas pour toute
la vie oui moi j'ai eu deux ans
d'inelligibilité en 96 on est en 2001 et
aujourd'hui il y a quelques mois quand
je suis revenu le maire a dit oh ben je
vais appeler la Cour des comptes dans le
fond il pourrait peut-être nous redonner
encore un peu d'argent et puis on va le
condamner une deuxième fois en France il
y a pas double peine en Europe non plus
quand vous avez été condamné pour un
fait d'accord vous ne pouvez pas être
condamné
bon voilà bon et j'ai payé des dommages
et intérêts à la ville et j'ai été
lourdement imposé car en plus on m'a
pris ça en avantage en nature vous êtes
obligé de vendre un appartement oui on
va en parler alors vous avez été élu
sans étiquette un DVD ce qui est à
droite c'est assez
voilà voilà
donc vous avez voté évidemment ça c'est
moderne comme truc alors que Chazeau
votre concurrent du RPR lui les RP
officiel et puis en plus c'est l'ami de
MAM de Michel Alliot-Marie vous pensez
que c'est la desservice hein je ne sais
pas c'est une femme charmante demeurant
mais il avait effectivement toutes les
avait
toutes les investitures toutes ça lui a
pas servi à grand chose c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire ah il y en a d'autres
mais il vous accuse de clientélisme et
de populisme c'est vrai que tous ces
mères qui sont très aimés c'est souvent
parce qu'ils font du clientélisme c'est
quoi le clientélisme si c'est s'occuper
des gens quand ils ont un problème quand
ils ont un problème d'appartement quand
ils ont un problème d'emploi mais oui
alors ça je suis pour
Alain Barrière Alain Barrière bravo
c'est pas le blague test mais déjà vous
commencez bien toujours pas sur le
public
Patrick Balkany vous êtes né en 48 à
Neuilly-sur-Seine votre père s'appelait
Giulia c'est ça jula oui immigré juif
hongrois résistant des portées il a fait
fortune dans le prêt-à-porter de luxe
les magasins retis moi je me souviens de
ça il y avait des voitures publicitaires
absolument très ça marqué mon enfance
alors il y avait des magasins aux
Champs-Élysées Faubourg Saint-Honoré et
vous est-ce qu'on peut dire vous êtes un
petit peu un fils à papa non oui sauf
que j'ai commencé par travailler dans le
prêt-à-porter
absolument
alors vous allez dans les pensions
plutôt select au collège du Montcel
Jouy-en-Josas soluble vous partagez une
chambre avec Michel Sardou oh oui 4 ans
même
la semaine dernière et après et après on
était avec Fugain au cours de comédie
dans un lycée privé en Suisse
effectivement vous avez fait un cours
d'art dramatique vous êtes débrouillé
pour faire du cinéma exact et vous allez
jouer dans J'ai tué Raspoutine
il faisait le grand duc Dimitri voilà
c'est un film de Robert Hossein en fait
comédien au départ oui mais il est resté
en quelque sorte sauf que je joue mon
propre texte voilà et puis alors après
vous faites votre service militaire et
là vous êtes un petit peu pistonné pour
rentrer à l'après j'ai eu un gros coup
de peau je suis arrivé à l'Élysée un peu
par hasard voilà je suis passé du
Bourget à l'Élysée je vous aimez mes
classes
avait des copains etc bon et puis c'est
vrai que Réty c'était en face de
l'Élysée elle se fait des amis
ouais tu m'étonnes voilà alors vous êtes
donc au service de presse de la
présidence pendant la présidence de
Georges Pompidou mesdames je salue ici
Georges est une orgas et donc vous
portez vous portez les dépêches mais
maintenant dans votre curriculum
vitalité vous dites vous êtes passés au
cabinet de Georges Pompidou c'est quand
même j'ai toujours fait j'ai toujours
dit que j'avais fait mon service
militaire à l'Élysée j'étais très
heureux parce que à 22 ans c'est vrai
que je faisais la revue de presse du
Président de la République et que toutes
les heures j'amenais les dépêches de
toutes les agences de presse et c'était
c'est un service somme toute très
sympathique et qui vous ouvre des
perspectives c'est vrai donc jusque là
pas trop de problèmes voilà une vie
plutôt sympa et alors après le service
vous rencontrez celle qui est devenu
votre femme Isabelle Smadja donc est une
fille d'une famille assez fortunée aussi
oui on peut le dire
familier à Soustelle Lazaref son nom que
c'était le patron de combat Hadja et
donc ça vous permet quand même d'accéder
assez vite centrale du RPR à un moment
de la création 76 77 non j'étais j'étais
dans les 100 premiers membres du comité
central oui alors donc Pasqua vous vous
remarque à cette époque et vous devenez
ce qu'on appelle un Pasqua boy oui
a donné leur chance à beaucoup de jeunes
en 83 qui ont été élus dans un certain
nombre de élus donc à Levallois aux
municipales maire de Levallois réélu en
89 vous êtes député en 88 et vous
resterez maire de Levallois jusqu'en 95
les députés jusqu'en 97 voilà exactement
et un petit rond
alors quand vous êtes maire de Levallois
vous vous transformez que cette banlieue
populaire en une espèce de nuit quoi
c'est pas une espèce de Neuilly c'est
une ville où il y a 55000 habitants et
50 000 emplois parce que quand je suis
arrivé dans la ville il y avait que des
usines qui étaient en train de
péricliter il y avait l'usine de deux
chevaux Citroën qui était en train de
fermer et pour l'économie de la ville il
a fallu faire venir des entreprises se
battre avec les pouvoirs publics pour
construire des des bureaux des logements
des équipements en tout genre et je les
fais pendant 12 ans et je crois que les
levaloisiens ont été très heureux de
toute cette transformation qui viennent
de vous réélire donc voilà bon alors
vous créez une pénis municipale oui
alors ils avaient on les appelait les
cowboys c'est vrai oui non c'était la
première police municipale qui a été
créée en Île-de-France voilà
ouais 357 normal mais ils sont tous
armés c'est pour toute sécurité et on a
créé aussi la vidéo surveillance on a
été aussi les premiers et maintenant
tout le monde réclame et des polices
municipales et de la vidéo surveillance
[Musique]
partout il y en a partout
vous avez choisi
[Musique]
comme ça oh je suis pas sûr que ça soit
vraiment le remède pour pas être agressé
à Gennevilliers à chaque fois je
traversais Levallois j'avais peur de me
faire agresser par votre police
municipale je vous jure
en tout cas vous vous avez été condamné
en attendant donc nous pour l'instant ça
va quoi plus vite
[Musique]
ça balance bien non ce qu'on peut dire
quand même c'est que vous êtes
transformé un peu Levallois en une sorte
de Monaco non il y a une espèce de petit
endroit comme ça surprotégé non mais
c'est vrai c'est un c'est une ville où
il fait bon vivre ouais
bien alors vous achetez un appartement
enfin 500 mètres carrés en face de la
mairie construit par j'ai quitté Neuilly
pour partir à Levallois
mais quand ils ont construit l'immeuble
vous êtes réservé un duplex de 500
mètres carrés on avait un appartement à
Neuilly on est vendu en a racheté à
Levallois bon c'est comme tout le monde
c'est là où travaillait donc les
fameuses employés municipaux qui vous
ont été tellement
municipaux venait m'aider lorsque
j'avais besoin d'eux voilà et là il y a
un problème c'est que le juge alfen le
fameux juge à le Fendt s'intéresse aux
HLM des Hauts-de-Seine et surtout au
directeur de l'Office des HLM des
Hauts-de-Seine Didier Schuller et là une
sombre histoire où le beau-père du juge
alphène monsieur maréchal et mêlé à une
tentative de chantage sur Schuller enfin
c'est ce que vous en tous les cas vous
accrédité comme thèse vous dites je ne
sais pas lequel des deux donc entre
Schuller et alfen risque le plus la
prison
écoutez c'est de la très vieille
histoire
c'est une très très
c'était visiblement une histoire de
famille entre maréchal et alphène son
beau-père elle juge moi je suis jamais
rentré là-dedans dans tous les cas le
juge a été dans un premier temps décisif
du dossier le jugement à cause de cette
affaire maréchal et puis plus tard il a
quand même été lavé de tout soupçon
c'est à dire qu'il y a eu une annulation
de la procédure voilà tout simplement
vous pensez qu'il y avait vraiment un
vrai problème pensez pas que c'est un
montage total ah non absolument pas ah
bon absolument pas là parce que votre
ami soulleur lui part au Bahamas non je
crois qu'il a eu très peur
c'était le directeur de l'office de HLM
donc des Hauts-de-Seine et lui il est
parti au Bahamas quand il a vu arriver
tout ça et ensuite quand vous perdez la
mairie en 95 et vous êtes condamné lui
vous balance quand même Schuler non
je ne sais pas j'ai jamais eu de
nouvelles vous savez
malheureusement il est pas revenu ou
malheureusement il est parti il aurait
jamais dû partir d'ailleurs donc vous
dites malheureusement sérieusement non
sérieusement parce que je crois que il y
a vraiment pas grand chose dans les dans
les dossiers
c'est pas la ferraille fin après vous
vous allez prendre avec votre femme donc
ça s'arrange pas vous séparez pendant un
an oui mais vous savez dans un couple ça
fait 25 ans qu'on est marié de temps en
temps j'ai pris la petite clé
et vous êtes là
[Applaudissements]
en 97 je t'explique du groupe RPR donc à
l'Assemblée nationale en 97 on est
dissous ouais vous savez ouais on devait
aller jusqu'à 98 à 97 on est mis en
vacances voilà voilà je me représente
pas et je prends deux années sabbatiques
aux Caraïbes en France juste à côté en
France à Saint-Martin bien en France à
Saint-Martin ville française vous savez
qui t'apprendre deux années sabbatique
autant les prendre à Saint-Martin à
Aubervilliers entre nous pour trouver
Stéphane Collaro Carlos
la fête les gens qui passent c'est les
gens qui habitent là-bas
Johnny il vient il a il lui aussi il a
pris 6 mois sabbatique à Saint-Martin et
vous dirigez une radio dans un endroit
qui s'appelle marigot mais non c'est la
capitale de Saint-Martin ouais mais
c'est fou quand même non vous avez
vraiment l'esprit
et votre femme fait de la décoration
[Rires]
tout ça c'est très agréable
quand on y passe qu'un jour c'est très
bien un mois c'est vrai qu'au bout de
deux ans vous finissez
dans votre ville
tu crois pas si bien
c'est que lorsque
Patrick revient avec sa famille Isabelle
l'appartement ayant été vendu ils sont
obligés de l'habiter chez leur fille oui
parce que ma fille habite à Levallois
quand on est à Levallois elle nous mais
c'est grand chez elle non mais
rassurez-vous elle est célibataire ah
bon d'accord vous êtes pas les instruire
elle est célibataire je vais même vous
dire elle vous adore la 24 ans
ouais ouais le mec vend sa fille à la
télé alors là si ça c'est pas un homme
politique je me retrouve avec 500 mètres
carrés mais ça va pas traîner bien à toi
les employés de mairie
de mairie parce que quand je suis parti
il y en avait 1100 la figurez-vous quand
je reviens il y en a 14 ans oui c'est
quand même extraordinaire et moi j'en
utilisais que de temps en temps alors
vous voyez il y en a qui les utilisent
pas 300 trouver la ville dans quel état
là sérieux bah un peu dégradé très
honnêtement c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qui
m'aurait lu hein c'est pas par hasard
pour mettre dans les Magnum non ils ont
des villes ils ont des trottoirs sales
ils ont une ville
je n'ai jamais pu monsieur quand je
passe j'ai peur de votre ville votre
police municipale est effrayante je vous
jure que c'est pas vrai ils ont des
grands des dents et tout non ça c'est
plutôt ça non non je vous jure je vous
jure votre police avec les gens qui
n'ont rien à se reprocher n'ont jamais
peur de la police je suis un bandit je
serai pas là sinon j'avais peur en
passant de votre ville qui est le bandit
vous faites vous allez faire rire là
mais pas pour le comique
je vous parle d'un truc que j'ai
vraiment fait du cœur
ça m'a toujours dégoûté ça de passer à
Levallois ça se voit que j'ai pas la
gueule de Levallois et il y a la police
municipale qui est derrière il fait op
toi viens voir papier tout ça qu'est-ce
que tu fous là je vous jure sur la tête
de ma mère que c'est vrai la police
municipale n'arrête jamais quelqu'un
pour lui donner
d'abord et je vous
assure quand même avec des armes à la
poche et des bons de lacrymo même sans
même sans la police nationale eh ça doit
être à Chicago ou alors vous avez vu ça
dans des films de série de vidéos de
surveillance mais je vous jure c'est
vrai monsieur je vous jure bon vous êtes
en train de faire rire tout le Valois
Serge
sérieusement
est-ce que vous pensez que en étant
parti dans les conditions qu'on connaît
en revenant en vous faisant élire est-ce
que vous pensez que vous aidez la
politique en agissant de la sorte mais
moi je ne cherche pas à aider la
politique je cherche à aider la ville
dans laquelle je travaille depuis tant
d'années à progresser à aller de l'avant
j'essaye d'aider les levaloisiens moi
j'ai fait de la politique pour aider les
autres pour servir uniquement comme vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure j'avais pas
besoin de faire de la politique je suis
né dans une famille où on avait tout ce
qu'il fallait il y avait une affaire il
y avait tout ce qu'il fallait je n'avais
vraiment pas besoin de politique pour
gagner de l'argent comme certains
voudraient le laisser dire ou laisser
entendre moi j'ai fait de la politique
vraiment par conviction et je continue à
faire de la politique
personnel c'est pour la ville et ça l'a
toujours été et ça continuera à l'être
mon épouse aussi et votre action votre
retour votre élection pour l'image de la
politique des hommes politiques vous
pensez que c'est bénéfique vous savez je
sais pas si l'image des hommes
politiques est aussi bénéfique pour moi
en tout cas que je me rends compte d'une
chose c'est que sans investiture je suis
élu d'autre avec les investitures de
tous les partis ne sont pas élus très
bien on allume
[Applaudissements]
bien
on va passer maintenant à une petite
interview spécial si vous le voulez bien
on la bouche pas pendant le jingle
[Musique]
bien l'interview moralité est-ce que
vous avez déjà piqué dans le
porte-monnaie de votre maman quand vous
étiez petit
dans le porte-monnaie de ma maman oh
j'ai sûrement dû prendre de quoi aller
acheter à carambar oui
est-ce que vous êtes déjà sorti avec la
copine d'un copain
j'ai beaucoup de copains
un commerçant se trompe à votre avantage
en vous rendant la monnaie vous lui
faites remarquer oui tout de suite ça
m'arrive et ça me ça m'arrive
malheureusement souvent je trouve que
les gens comptent de plus en plus mal si
votre côté fils de commerce vous pensez
à vos parents non c'est mon côté net
j'aime pas qu'on me rende de l'argent
qui ne m'appartient pas c'est pas
l'interview mensonge là c'est non c'est
la vérité vous imaginez c'est un jeu de
l'esprit vous avez un appartement vous
possédez un appartement votre locataire
peut plus payer le loyer c'est un type
odieux mais vraiment odieux il y a deux
enfants insupportable vous les foutez
dehors jamais non je d'abord je loue pas
d'appartement parce que je voudrais
surtout pas me retrouver dans ce genre
de situation j'aime pas ça et quand
j'étais président de l'Office
départemental de HLM c'est-à-dire 30000
logements dans les Hauts-de-Seine croyez
moi avant d'expulser quelqu'un il
fallait vraiment qu'on puisse pas
arriver à d'autres solutions j'ai
toujours fait en sorte que les gens
soient relogés soit aider ni des
enquêteurs ni des assistantes sociales
non
je l'ai fait par conviction rien d'autre
je l'ai fait je n'ai pas pris les
tambourser
comme ça mais je suis pas de droite
non non je sais pas ce que c'est la
gauche et la droite j'étais gaulliste la
gauche s'est partagée quand on a
beaucoup d'argent c'est partager avec
les autres c'est pas gueuler de payer
trop d'impôts toute la journée parce
qu'on sait que ça sert à faire des
hôpitaux oh vous savez aujourd'hui je
sais pas j'ai pas l'impression alors ça
a dû changer ça a dû beaucoup changer la
gauche partagée comment vous avez dit
partager
le pouvoir non en ce moment l'argent on
vous cite à l'ordre du mérite pour un
acte héroïque en fait vous n'avez pas
fait vous étiez là quand ça s'est
produit et vous vous c'est pas vous qui
avez sauvé le môme de se faire écraser
est-ce que vous dites rien vous prenez
la médaille
oh non au contraire je la remets à celui
qui l'a fait
et maintenant nous arrivons au climax de
cette émission madame messieurs c'est le
blind test
un blind test ce soir en hommage à
Charles Trenet donc nous entendrons des
reprises de chansons de Charles Trenet
par d'autres interprètes et ce que je
vous demanderais à vous tous ici c'est
de me donner les interprètes bien
entendu parce que les titres des
chansons les connaît mais d'abord pour
animer
arbitrer ce blind test mention Philippe
au quartier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
ce soir non puisque c'est Charles Trenet
le soleil qui avait rendez-vous avec la
lune d'accord ça te plaît ça me plaît
beaucoup la jusqu'ici tout va bien je
trouve tes amis fort charmantes
et voilà voilà
bien alors attention merci
commence Didier première chanson
[Musique]
c'est compliqué
oui c'est compliqué vous avez dit Eddy
Mitchell vous avez dit Eddy Mitchell et
vous avez dit Claude François et vous
avez tous raison parce qu'effectivement
c'est Eddy Mitchell et Claude François
donc un partout donc partout
deuxième chanson Didier
sur le toit de l'hôtel je vise avec toi
quand j'attends ta venue mon ami
contre une
chatte les chats
[Musique]
bravo
bravo bravo bravo bravo oh là là là là
là
[Musique]
la première fois
je l'ai crié attention
est-ce qu'on peut faire un petit replay
s'il vous plaît
je suis désolé je suis désolé ça nous
aura permis de me connaître en même
temps Marie bravo le contrôle vidéo
donc ça fait on en est où sur les points
là même deux mènent par deux points
voilà très bien bien alors Didier
chanson numéro 3
bien bien égalité
bah oui tu as une vraie culture hein
bien on continue quatre DJ
[Musique]
Chantal Goya
bles
bien chanson numéro 5
le bateau et tout ça tu danses alors
Mireille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les deux quand même maintenant c'est
passé très compliqué je lui envoie juste
les écouter Didier
[Musique]
de la mer
le prénom français ouais bravo
incroyable mais vrai c'est en fait vous
connaissez ça vous c'est incroyable vous
appelez comment
vous êtes une star
[Musique]
pour les lunes chanson numéro 7 Didier
très compliqué
très compliqué c'est un brésilien
pourquoi j'ai l'air
on lui fait un compliment
alors maintenant chanson numéro 8 Didier
[Musique]
je voudrais qu'on passe à la chanson
numéro 10
[Musique]
longtemps
québécois est belge
si vous trouvez ça vous êtes forte
Didier mets-moi la petite chanson là qui
vient dans le 10 là
[Musique]
alors attention super banco Didier toute
la route de France
[Musique]
il faut la prendre la carbone à 7 que
l'on soit deux trois quatre cinq six
beau
de retrouver quand même
les lunes de notre nouvelle
dans le titre du groupe il y a lune
dans le titre du groupe
ce sont les tueurs de la lune de miel
voilà qui l'avait dit
viens viens
c'est des bons chanteurs
alors elle est nommée dans la catégorie
au César meilleur jeune espoir féminin
pour son rôle dans ça de Benoît Jacquot
voici Isid Le Besco mesdames messieurs
bonsoir alors le 24 février donc vous
êtes on vous attend 24 février parce que
vous êtes meilleur jeune espoir féminin
enfin vous n'êtes pas la seule
évidemment c'est le problème il y en a
quelques-unes autres mais vous avez
commencé très jeune vous aviez pas
encore 10 ans vous avez tourné dans
Latner et Daniel Auteuil d'ailleurs et
j'ai fait des courts métrages
la puce et c'est en voyant ce film que
Benoit Jacquot vous a engagé pour être
Emilie de Lancry donc on l'a dit une
jeune fille de bonne famille qui est
initié sexuellement par le marquis votre
père était choqué effacer ce film quand
même non
mon grand-père ça va aider mon père il
était à l'intérêt de savoir elle était
surpris bah oui parce que ça ça fait un
peu peur à tout le monde au départ donc
voilà et depuis que vous avez fait ce
film vous avez lu beaucoup de livres de
ça non
boudoir vous l'avez pas lu encore
et alors vous en tirez quoi ça vous en
concluez quoi
j'aime bien moi je trouve ça très bien
écrit et puis c'est drôle
ça vous choque pas vous moi je crois
qu'il faisait ça plutôt pour pour
choquer sur le plan sexuel dans votre
vie sexuelle ça a changé quelque chose
de dire ça non pas du tout
le livre n'a eu aucune influence sur
vous
[Musique]
personnellement je le crois pas mais bon
Justine sur son sur sa table de nuit ne
change rien c'est
leur sexuel
donc non il y a qu'est-ce que vous avez
là c'est quoi c'est votre chapeau non
c'est un cadeau pour vous donc
très plaisir
on va parler de Dieu Babylone c'est
comment on fait
si vous prenez mon cadeau et que vous le
mettez
je le fais pour faire plaisir je vais
mettre votre cadeau et vous allez faire
ça il y a une poche c'est bien pour
mettre
tout ce que je veux si je mets le
chapeau mais tout ce que je veux
regarder tout le long
tu sais quand tu fais ça
merci Catherine
ta gueule
tu vas aller le voir
ça fait con ça fait vraiment
alors on fait ici souvent une interview
qui s'appelle interview prise de tête on
a été prise de tête cette des sujets
graves et ces questions les posent
toujours à des adultes à des gens qui
ont 30-45 ans et je me suis dit ça
serait intéressant d'avoir votre avis à
vous donc ça s'appelle l'interview prise
de tête
on le sait tout le monde le sait ne
touche pas pendant le cigare
vous savez tout le monde a bougé Serge
si je remets le chapeau vous bougez pas
[Applaudissements]
franchement Thierry ça te dirait pas une
petite pétanque
[Applaudissements]
ça passe très bien il faut aimer être
soumis pour mettre ça oui vraiment oh
non soumission
bien donc prise de tête vous êtes prête
là
est-ce que vous êtes je sais pas des
questions compliquées c'est juste votre
avis est-ce que vous êtes favorable au
divorce
bien sûr
la question se pose si déjà la question
se pose c'est que ça va ça doit pas
aller très bien donc mieux vaut qu'il
divorcent quoi bon vous êtes favorable
au divorce je suis pas favorable divorce
si on si les gens déjà ils ont décidé de
se marier et ben
il se pose la question c'est que oui
est-ce que vous êtes favorable à la
fidélité dans le couple
bah ça c'est pareil moi forcément si on
me demande bah oui pour moi oui pour les
autres ça les regarde il y en a qui sont
toute manière là quand je dis tout ça
non mais c'est juste ça
ça veut rien dire parce que
vous adapter cette boîte à chaque fois
différent quoi
et que je l'aime vraiment mais quand
même temps
enfin on peut jamais savoir quoi c'est
bête en tout cas
déçus chez eux est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à l'adoption d'enfant pour des
couples homosexuels
un peu brûlants on sort on va gagner 20
minutes
qu'elle soit des homosexuels ou pas
les cons c'est des cons quoi
ça vous choque des couples homosexuels
puissent adapter des enfants ou ça vous
choque pas écoutez
c'est difficile de d'y répondre moi
personnellement au départ comme ça je
suis contre si on doit dire pour ou
contre je dirais contre après il y a un
grand débat là-dessus
est-ce qu'un enfant sera plus malheureux
en maison de enfin la danse où est-ce
qu'il sera plus malheureux avec des
parents homos là on le sait pas donc
c'est après il y a tout un débat mais
c'est vrai que sur le principe
il vaut mieux avoir des parents
homosexuels sympas que des parents
étaient homosexuels c'est un débat
alorsement vous êtes pour ou contre
la peine de mort j'imagine que vous êtes
contre la peine de mort comme nous tous
mais est-ce que vous êtes contre la
peine de mort pour les assassins
d'enfants en fait par exemple
si c'est mon enfant que qui les la peine
de mort ou qu'il aille en prison pour
moi c'est pas et sauf si je le tue moi
après que ce soit quelqu'un d'autre
qu'il tue bon j'aurais envie de le tuer
moi mais
ça dépend les circonstances mais sans
doute
prise de tête moi j'y vais
alors pour cette interview prise de tête
et pour les autres d'ailleurs beaucoup
de gens m'envoient des emails en disant
pourquoi tu demandes pas cette question
donc vous pouvez continuer à envoyer les
questions vous m'en verrez je les
poserai si on va faire des emails
d'ailleurs
alors je salue Frédéric d'Argentan tout
le monde s'en fout bien entendu je salue
Jean-Jacques Paladini tout le monde s'en
fout Rachida tout le monde s'en fout
vas-y enchaîne ah oui si si il y a un
truc c'est qu'il y a de moi que quand il
avait fait la promo de son bouquin il
avait mis son numéro de téléphone dans
le journal son livre Alice à corteaux et
les gens me disent oui mais enfin il
paraît qu'il a changé de numéro de
téléphone mais on a le nouveau ouais 06
62 37 61 60
de 37 61 60 appelé Yann Moix ça lui fera
plaisir tant que tu es parti pour la
déconne le numéro perso Thierry
tu as envie de jouer ça
47 42
et maintenant
j'accueille Stomy Bugsy et Yazid ait
comment ça va la pêche la pêche
avril qui s'appelle de l'amour avec
Virginie Ledoyen marsouppé Jean-François
Stévenin et Bruno poudzulu réalisé par
Jean-François Richer alors on va en
parler mais d'abord on va prendre un
petit peu de vos nouvelles
sur le plan musical vous en êtes où
plan musical j'ai fait une petite
tournée dans toutes les banlieues des
petites salles de 600 personnes 1000
personnes là où ça chauffe bien et je
sortirai un nouveau single dans un mois
à peu près bien je vous répondez sur le
même temps que je vous posais la
question Didier
[Musique]
la vie c'est comme ça
le visage
à tous les étages la presse propagent
les bleus et leurs tumeurs
un cache dans le boys otage exploser
sondage
de l'Intérieur négocier avec son bip ça
ça sort le 12 juin
j'ai l'impression de votre style se
radicalise un peu non ouais c'est fini
les premières rigoles
il y a une chose pour tout là c'est le
temps de revenir au rap dur tant pis
pour les disques d'or j'ai dit que mes
ordures je reviens en rap dur ou
lala
ah mais je t'ai mis il est génial parce
que vous savez quand il quand il y a un
moment il faisait un peu des cases comme
ça alors il est arrivé chez des gens et
puis piquer des trucs et puis voyez les
photos il voyait les photos de la
famille il a tellement bon coeur qui
laissait les trucs mais alors qu'est-ce
qu'il faisait il allait dans les bureaux
puis que les ordinateurs parce que là il
y avait pas la photo des propriétaires
il y a bon cœur donc on est on est
retour au dur non c'est vrai là bientôt
avec ministère amère plan B oula mais
non il y en a pour parler de cinéma là
on va parler de cinéma alors d'accord
vous êtes une star de cinéma maintenant
non non si bien sûr
non on va parler de la tournée quand
même
non je veux pas que je donne les dates
tu es au courant de tout ça attends
c'est mon boulot
on va faire un peu la tournée là
le vin le 20 avril à Marseille le 5 mai
à Nanterre le 7 mai à Toulon le 13 à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye le 16 mai toujours
à Bordeaux le 17 à Toulouse et le 18 à
Lyon voilà
alors vous vous aviez sorti un album
aussi
et plus engagé que vous les femmes ouais
c'est sûr
ça a adhéré pas trop à ce qui aux
influences qui qui en ce moment dans le
hip-hop c'est-à-dire les terres
margotiques tout ça j'ai fait ça plus
textuel donc ça a pas trop intéressé ce
que le rap intéresse en général
vous allez remettre ça j'espère vous
êtes engagé vous un peu quand même dans
le mouvement l'intégration la banlieue
tout ça non un peu moins maintenant mais
je l'ai été pas mal c'est comme ça que
vous avez rencontré Jean-François Richer
c'est comme ça que j'ai rencontré
Jean-François
depuis qu'il est une star de cinéma il
fait plus la pomme comment il se lave ça
alors
je tiens beaucoup à ça donc de l'amour
le pitch donc Maria interprété par
Virginie Ledoyen qui vit chez des
parents vieillissants dans une cité son
père c'est Jean-Marc Thibault s'est tout
dire elle est chômeuse en stage elle
gagne 2000 balles par mois dans une
usine de siège
elle parle de son aller de quitter son
boulot mais elle est toujours là et on
parle avec sa copine Linda qui est jouée
par Marsault douppet alors
extraordinaire cette actrice je
connaissais pas alors heureusement
heureusement Virginie Ledoyen a un petit
ami qui s'appelle Karim et qui jouait
par yaziz c'est-à-dire que lui c'est
votre premier film gros c'est le
deuxième en fait le premier n'est pas
encore sorti il sortira après tout de
suite il a une scène d'amour avec une
loyal mec
voilà je suis gouré de boulot et voilà
c'est comme ça c'est un film un peu
militant quand même non
ouais si on veut toute façon il peut pas
s'empêcher Jean-François comme il est
assez politisé il peut pas s'empêcher de
mettre des petits ingrédients mais c'est
vraiment un film sur l'amour basé sur le
sentiment plus que sur le militantisme
très bien
je sais pas je vais pas l'air content là
pour servir un film c'est pas comme si
je venais à la musique pour servir du
story Buzzi pour tu vois je suis quand
tu es acteur enfin quand vous êtes
acteur vous avez une un autre
comportement que quand vous êtes
chanteur
une grosse machine c'est un ensemble
tout donc tu peux pas venir faire ton
zouave comme ça parce que derrière il y
a du travail tout ça ou là attention
ah ouais les acteurs c'est ça moi je
sais pas je m'étais acteur mais si
j'étais acteur par exemple je devrais me
la péter un peu comme ça quoi
[Musique]
bien alors justement donc comme vous
êtes acteur on va vous faire le
questionnaire de Proust normal on se la
pète on se la pète pas
pour vous cette Bugsy c'est quoi le
comble de la misère
de la misère de la galère de pas pouvoir
nourrir ses enfants
[Musique]
et vous de jamais pouvoir en sortir
pour quelle faute avez-vous le plus
d'indulgence
ça vous apprendra
le mensonge peut-être je sais pas le
mensonge
et vous
ouais
quel est votre personnage historique
favori
en tout cas c'est des impressionnistes
peut-être Cézanne
la qualité que vous préférez chez
l'homme
bon courage
aussi
aucune
et chez la femme peut vous inspirer
peut-être
la sensibilité peut-être et vous stomie
la fidélité
non non
qui auriez-vous aimé être si vous
n'étiez pas Stomy Bugsy
qui par exemple je sais pas soit mi-carc
à bras libérateur du Cap-Vert
soit Al Pacino
c'est pour ça que c'est compliqué un
défaut je sais pas
[Musique]
c'est que je pense que je relativise
beaucoup trop ça m'empêche de d'être
vraiment content
naturel un peu sombre non passons
justement non non je suis je suis très
drôle normalement mais
si c'est vrai
qu'est-ce qui nous arrive non c'est
sincèrement je suis très drôle
normalement j'aime rire mais je
relativise beaucoup et ça m'empêche de
de vivre pleinement ce que je fais quoi
votre principal défaut cette amie
je sais pas non je sais pas
peut-être
en retard non je sais pas non non je
sais pas franchement je sais c'est pas
un défaut ça c'est l'heure qui a changé
le don de la nature que vous voudriez
avoir et vous n'avez pas voler voler
vous l'avez déjà fait en même temps
[Musique]
moi je te la joue au Marcel Proust c'est
clair
ça t'apprendra t'inquiète pas je vais
revenir dans le prochain pour un album
un truc avant [ __ ] la merde
votre devise Yazid
non rien sans rien
et vous baise la vie sinon elle baisera
riche avec yazida
bouzounou et jean-Françoise et
maintenant mesdames messieurs
[Musique]
d'un peuple qui a beaucoup souffert ou
si Dieudonné
ça va bonjour chanter très bien très
bien
ce qui s'est dit sujet de François
Mitterrand
vous en pensez quoi vous je ne suis pas
le seul être issu d'un peuple qui a
beaucoup souffert visiblement
visiblement mais ça fait rire quand il
s'agit des Noirs en général on arrive
visiblement cette chaîne dérange
personne alors que
la misère et la douleur est au moins
aussi profonde et je remarque que la
chanson de Tonton David en tout cas elle
exprime cette douleur mais elle est là
pour présenter dans une sorte de bonne
humeur comme ça allez les Noirs c'est
marrant vous êtes gentils
et je trouve je trouve c'est un peu
normal
je crois que je suis pas tout seul à le
trouver c'est un petit peu pesant parce
que parce qu'on a on a souffert on a
vraiment souffert c'était pas pour
rigoler non mais je suis non mais je
suis rentré sur une chanson qui disait
vous savez c'est un peu plaqué beaucoup
souffert
il y a le jazz aussi qui dit ça et
autrement dit
mais il l'a fait c'était c'était je
crois dans le but de vous dire quelque
chose et je suis pas persuadé que vous
êtes que vous auriez envoyé cette ce
jingle sur les propos de Monsieur tout à
l'heure je suis pas persuadé que vous
l'auriez fait je trouve ça et je trouve
ça regrettable vous savez pourquoi j'ai
mis cette chanson Dieudonné non mais je
sais pas ce qu'on vous va souvent à la
télé et maintenant on vous voit à la
télé à chaque fois vous râlez justement
et donc
exactement
d'amitié pour ce que vous faites je vous
trouve en plus très drôle et
politiquement souvent c'est juste et en
tout cas courageux de vous battre à
Dreux je vous trouve un tout petit peu
parano mais c'est tout est-ce que tu me
trouves est-ce que vous me trouvez
parano
je dis simplement que oui mais je trouve
simplement que il faudrait un moment
donné prendre au sérieux la souffrance
d'une partie de cette communauté mais
c'est une souffrance très sérieuse il y
a encore des gens aujourd'hui qui ont
des problèmes de pour se loger et c'est
souvent et systématiquement la même
communauté et je trouve que c'est que
c'est un peu regrettable
systématiquement de montrer un peu bon
allez les noirs
Luther King font partie d'un patrimoine
universel enfin je veux dire c'est c'est
pas il y a pas chacun défense en bout de
terre moi je suis prêt à me battre pour
pour tous les les dames de la terre et
je crois que vous aussi donc pas sûr
bien évidemment mais comprenez un petit
peu mon d'étonnement quand je rentre
dans une sorte de cirque comme ça
effectivement
je pense que Tonton David quand il a
écrit cette chanson il voulait dire
quelque chose de très de très profond
voilà c'est ce que je suis en train
ironique et je découvre que finalement
j'avais raison vous avez perdu toute
votre ironie
non il semble que je l'ai gardé au
contraire j'espère pour vous en tous les
cas non mais vous inquiétez pas pour moi
d'y arriver c'est gentil en tout cas de
vous préoccuper de mon ironie et puis de
ma dimension humoristique
avant il était super rigolo et tout
maintenant il est devenu acteur il se la
pète comme un malade vous
vous avant
vous encore une fois on peut pas dire je
suis pas content de chrétien je suis
très concerné par le problème simplement
c'est vrai qu'à un moment ça devient
casse-couilles et à force de le répéter
je crois que vous servez pas votre cause
si je peux me permettre
alors moi ce que j'ai à vous dire c'est
vous me dites en tant chrétien donc déjà
nous sommes français vous me dites en
tant que chrétien en tant chrétien vous
appartenez une communauté tout à fait
bon donc vous tolérez que j'appartiens à
une communauté oui laquelle
je sais pas moi quelle communauté vous
appartenez moi à vous m'avez dit oui
donc laquelle à votre avis la communauté
des noirs
a tendance à trop cette mississer que ce
soit les tribus
de mon livre et ça ça m'intéresse mais
moi je travaille pour l'instant
vous gonflez avec vos histoires de
chrétiens vous êtes pas plus chrétiens
vous en république vous êtes français
vous êtes pas juifs vous êtes français
on est tous français
républicaine effectivement et même même
si j'ai mes origines tu as tes origines
tu les as et cetera et je pense pendant
une demi-heure de problème de la
communauté juive parler de Vichy on
parlait d'autre chose en fait
je pense effectivement que un monde où
les Juifs se battent pour les Juifs les
noirs pour les noirs les arabes pour les
Arabes et les chrétiens pour les
chrétiens c'est un monde un peu triste
et je préfère la fraternité humaine moi
je suis la laïcité voilà maintenant
quand je vous ai écouté je reviens vous
avez parlé pendant 3/4 d'heure du
problème j'ai fait essentiellement de
Vichy l'histoire de France c'est très
bien l'histoire de France mais il y a
aussi dans l'histoire de France et une
partie de l'histoire dont on ne parle
jamais ni dans les bouquins d'histoire
si c'est 300 ans d'esclavage on en parle
pas on a pas assez je sais je comment on
parle pas assez de la guerre d'Algérie
fantôme à ouvrir si moi je m'en occupe
pas qu'il va le faire j'espère que c'est
peut-être le votre prochain bouquin
c'est possible mais en tout cas moi il
est bien logique qu'à un moment donné
ayant accès à cette tribune j'explique
mais même si je me réveille je rigole un
petit peu parce que il faut savoir
rigoler à un moment donné parce que la
situation est tellement clairement vous
savez rigoler en direct ah bon venez
voir mon spectacle donc à partir du 23
juin et
le diable tous et pour vous faire rire
je vous répète que je trouve qu'à un
moment ça risque de desservir votre
cause ce côté sans arrêt comme ça de
venir à la télé pour râler ça risque de
desservir votre cause la cause que vous
défendez les problèmes des Noirs ils ont
jamais été réglés ils sont dans les
oubliettes c'est pas vrai regardez le 22
mai le jour de l'abolition l'esclavage
il est pas fêté c'est un jour on fête la
Pentecôte mes couilles trucs
en fait on fait tout sauf le jour de de
l'abolition d'esclavage
[Musique]
on peut quand même considérer que c'est
une tragédie dans l'histoire de
l'humanité et qu'à un moment ou un autre
site permanent une horreur et quand on
va au Sénégal là où partait les esclaves
d'ailleurs c'est un déchirement et c'est
pas simplement une rigolade
je dirais le combat des Noirs américains
et le combat des droits civique et le
combat en France peut-être que les
effectivement les Noirs français doivent
prendre exemple aussi sur sur une
émancipation si je m'inquiète de voir
des fois un peu trop sérieux c'est parce
que je voulais déjà dit après avoir eu
le film de Valérie Lemercier qui
s'appelait le derrière vous êtes un
super acteur et chaque fois que je vous
vois je vous le répète et c'est vrai je
comprends vous ayez envie de vous
occuper d'autres choses mais vous êtes
tellement bon quand vous jouez la
comédie et vous étiez tellement bon
quand vous êtes en spectacle sur scène
que des fois on regrette un peu ce dieu
donnait là voilà oui mais bon en même
temps on est très tellement peu nombreux
à pouvoir parler c'est pour ça il faut
on le disait tout à l'heure que emmener
à un moment donné c'est bien alors
Dieudo vous avez une fille qui s'appelle
Bonnie oui et elle doit souvent vous
poser des questions sur le sur la vie
sur les gens sur les idées donc ça va
vous valoir une interview expliquée à ma
fille
[Musique]
bien alors imaginez donc je suis votre
fille et je vous pose des questions
très compliqué pour vous papa c'est quoi
un bon bout là c'est un petit gâteau un
petit gâteau qui s'est vendu dans les
années 80
et il y avait un noir dessus j'ai grandi
avec ça
c'était une catastrophe
et aussi la tête de [ __ ] encore en
pâtisserie qui se vend très bien
vers ces étranges que ce soit
systématiquement sur une communauté en
particulier que ce type de choses
arrivent c'est vrai c'est regarder
réfléchissez il y a pas d'autres
pâtisserie
il y a pas de tête de chinois ou
non c'est vrai
oui il y a un grand chemise aussi
papa toujours votre fille Bonnie
pourquoi tu t'es pas présenté pour être
mère de Dreux
parce que comme dans beaucoup de villes
de France mon enfant tu sais
la droite c'est-à-dire au Front national
pour faire liste commune dès le premier
tour il faut se retirer il faut se
battre contre ces gens-là
donc je suis cette fois-ci retiré et
apporter mon soutien à la liste des
Jean-Pierre leage entre bon ben entre la
folie ambiance
dis-moi papa c'est vrai que tu vas être
président de la République oui je serai
le prochain président ma fille je serai
aussi le dernier
parce que c'est moi qui vais
démissionner cette fonction stupide il y
aura plus de président
qu'est-ce que tu crois il y a plus de
frontières déjà un président de quoi
chacun est président de chez soi
est-ce qu'on devrait tous avoir une
carte de citoyen du monde et qui est
plus de frontière plus de pays plus de
président
de la France bon c'est pas complètement
faux
dis papa
mais moi
dis papa tu avais dit qu'avec Jospin il
y aurait plus de 100 papiers et à la
télé on envoie encore
c'est mieux mais c'est pas gagné c'est
clair et pourquoi toi papa on ne voit
plus trop à la télé
bah si regarde ma fille j'y vais et puis
parce que tu sais je fais des films là
j'ai joué au théâtre tu es venu me voir
d'ailleurs tu as bien aimé le spectacle
tu es monté sur scène même hein
tu vas faire comme tu veux
pourquoi papa parce que je vais faire
comme semi Bugzy je vais être acteur
et papa pourquoi il y a pas il y a pas
beaucoup de noirs à la télé
ma fille tu sais ça s'est fait doucement
il y avait un Code noir il y a une
justice qui déterminait que l'homme noir
n'était pas égal à l'homme blanc même un
pape qui a dit que l'homme noir n'avait
pas de conscience tu sais ça remonte à
longtemps oui oui le dernier il n'a pas
dit ça évidemment mais mais il est issu
d'une vieille tradition et puis c'est un
c'est un monde qui qui a considéré que
l'homme noir n'est pas un homme était un
sous homme et encore quand on va
chercher du boulot quand on va au loge
et quand tu iras j'espère que ça sera
rangé d'ici là mais tu auras plus de
problèmes que les autres il va y avoir
plus de noir à la télé
oui je pense il y en a déjà un peu plus
donc ça va mieux oui bien sûr l'espoir
il est devant toute façon la merda c'est
derrière hein papa pourquoi le président
de la République Jacques Chirac il va
pas voir le juge qui l'a convoqué
parce que tu sais mon enfant
en ce moment il y a une chose très
importante qui est en train de se passer
derrière ça tu sais c'est qui détient
les bonnes valeurs et la morale la
justice ou les élus enfin on ne sait
plus tu sais on est dans un système en
même temps c'est de justice c'est la
même qui emprisonne des sans-papiers qui
tolèrent le commerce des bombes et des
armes
et de l'autre côté tu as un homme qui
qui lui représentant commerce justement
et puis en même temps ça m'étonnerait
qu'elle me parle de Jacques Chirac parce
que lui on n'a jamais parlé
papa c'est quoi les verres pourquoi ils
sont pas tous ouverts
c'est c'est une force politique qui
commence à grandir dans ce pays et puis
il faudra bien toute façon que toi que
ça se renouvelle et puis là il y a un
nouveau parti qui est plus proche plus
proche des autres plus proche de
l'environnement regarde en Afrique quand
tu vas chez grand-père chez papi c'est
des gens qui vivent pas pareil avec leur
environnement sont des vers aussi sont
des écolos ce sont des gens qui au
quotidien vivent dans une autre relation
qui sont pas dans une hystérie de la
productivité comme certains bon il y a
des avantages et des inconvénients tu as
vu quand tu vas chez papi
j'aime bien les chez Papy et papa c'est
vrai qu'il faut plus manger de Danone ah
oui ça c'est vrai ah c'est vrai parce
qu'à l'école on m'a dit on mange plus de
dananes chez nous on mange plus de dinde
la
[Applaudissements]
j'ai entendu Élie ton ancien copain qui
a dit à la radio que tu pensais qu'au
fric ben oui parce que il fallait bien
qu'il trouve quelque chose mais tu sais
bon bah lui il a vendu beaucoup de
cassettes il paye beaucoup plus d'impôts
papa donc ça l'énerve un petit peu mais
bon bon c'est son copain à papa d'accord
c'est quand même son copain un copain
reste encore
il vaut mieux aimer Jésus au Coluche
sont les mêmes ce sont deux grands
humoristes de l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
et papa comment on roule un joint
tiens va chercher la boîte là-bas
pourquoi on meurt
c'est très important c'est très
important ça arrive au moment où je
prévois pas et c'est mieux comme ça et
bah si tu meurs pas tu vis pas tu vois
c'est la mort la mort ça n'existe pas
c'est de mourir en fait c'est une
mauvaise question je sais pas qui t'a
posé cette question
c'est la petite semoule la petite
semoule c'est la petite semoule qui m'a
dit de Manzi à ton père
son balle élevé ces gens là c'est parce
que tu vas mourir que tu rigoles moins
qu'avant
non tu sais je rigole toujours autant tu
m'as vu quand même bon à la maison c'est
vrai que tu as fait des bêtises aussi
c'est normal que je rigole pas toujours
c'est vrai c'est vrai à ma puce mais
enfin
non non tu sais papa il a toujours
rigolé on a toujours été énervé en train
de lire minutes tu te souviens
vous voyez quand ton frère est rentré
dans la police
et pour arbitrer le blind test j'appelle
Monsieur Philippe Corti
voilà
bien voilà là c'est l'été c'est Ibiza là
c'est Ibiza et bientôt je vais finir à
poil dans cette émission
j'ai reçu sérieusement j'ai reçu un
email d'une fille qui disait pourquoi
elle est danseuses sont toujours comme
ça très dévêtus et pourquoi on voit
jamais sorti danser en string la semaine
prochaine alors voilà
c'est le blind test tout le monde écoute
spécialité de la messieurs bien
attention je veux le nom non non
c'est clair
et pour vous aussi
attention parce que c'est deux petites
choses c'est la première
réputation ça serait ridicule
franchement donc ne dis rien
vous êtes malin ah non je suis très bien
passé en rentrant vous serez mal avec
votre femme Didier
voilà voilà le soleil le chanteur le
chanteur chanter Manu Chao
j'ai peur
j'ai peur que ça soit la roche ah replay
Serge vas-y c'est incroyable
soleil
je pense je pense que Louis Nicolas lui
a soufflé c'est vous qui avez soufflé
j'ai entendu à la chose
d'avoir la chou il paraît qu'il ouvre
une fois par mois
alors on continue l'interprète
Louis Nicolas qui va Doc Gynéco blind
test c'est grand quand même merci
producteur aujourd'hui
il y en a beaucoup encore
la tricheuse
[Musique]
qui vont personne personne ne tournage à
trouver venez bonne personne
[Musique]
donc c'est l'équipe de lunettes il y a
trois lunettes la journée voir trois
lunettes Louis se fiche avec tout le
monde porte ses lunettes
parce que vous avez trois points grâce à
vous merci on continue
[Musique]
We Are The World
[Applaudissements]
5 à 2 donc 5 5 pour les lunettes et deux
pour les chapeaux et les deux points
faut bien dire son Dala à la roche
Didier
c'est pas facile version originale vous
la connaissez originale les Lovin
spoonful
la procurer Didier
toujours l'été ça
[Musique]
bravo
maintenant il y a le super bon alors le
super banco
c'est horrible
c'est faux c'est fou mais la vie est
injuste c'est un juste la loi du super
banco est un jeu c'est comme le tir au
but
mets un truc populaire
faut que le chat se calme qui
chante
elle est morte d'une overdose absolument
c'était tout en parle l'émission pas
comme les autres rendez-vous samedi
prochain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
latitude abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce
bleu